Please welcome to the stage.
[inaudible]
I
was just thinking about stage,
trying to figure out what I'm going to dive into because I use these folks as an
opportunity to the more deeply into what I've been thinking about.
I'm going to talk to you about,
we spoke,
I wrote 12 rules for life.
Let me say it,
but I don't,
I'm not parroting the books.
No,
I'm trying to make what I'm thinking about clearer.
I was thinking maybe a little story before it can for the talk,
but what exactly is it that we're going to address and I thought,
well,
I'm going to interest with relationship between perception,
reality.
I thought that's a very serious problem and it's so funny with the city at the
back of the stage and think back to them.
12 here,
welcome.
Like go and see [inaudible] listen to be carved for 70 minutes about,
it's a philosophical discussion,
really psychological discussion as well.
The relationship between perception and reality of who would have thought that
would be like a popular thing,
you know?
And so,
but I think it's a thing.
It's screening something.
Yeah.
Well reserve obviously a hunger that's the unmet for some reason for serious his
and that's great.
So that's what we're going to do.
We're going to have some written give tonight.
So
I'm going to stumble around with a bit tonight.
I think because this is a very difficult topic that I have gotten completely
clear in my head.
So,
uh,
hope you have to make this as coherent as possible.
See if what I'm going to be trying to solve at least to some degree is the
problem
of the relationship between value and reality.
We live in a world of value where things have gotten that material reality
itself cause the teeth to have any intrinsic value,
right?
It's sort of,
it's there and so objective and in some sense whatever value there is we
attribute to the world.
That's one way of looking at it anyways.
And that,
uh,
that that opens up questions about the reality of value.
It also,
so that's one thing I want to address.
The problem I want to address is how it is.
The perception is even possible because the world is an insanely complicated
place.
Like it's so complicated that it's really,
it's really beyond comprehension and so it is going is how it is to,
you can comprehend until that you could perceive it because it's actually
beyond,
it's so complex.
It's beyond your ability to proceed.
So,
so I'm trying to solve two problems at the same time is how in the world do you
manage this incredibly difficult job of perception and what role does value that
the idea of value,
the idea that one thing is worth more than another,
what role does that play in that?
You might say,
well why is that so relevant?
Well,
it's,
it's exactly relevant because if the problems,
problem relevance,
you have to assume that one thing is more important than another before you can
do anything.
Because to do something means that you privileged that thing above all the other
things that you could be doing,
you value anymore.
So without imposing a value structure on the world are discovering one within
the world.
I don't know which of those is true.
You can't eat an act if you have to add,
so you're stuck with it,
stuck with them.
It's not poured so much.
You start with the problem of value.
Okay,
so we're going to walk through them and see if like I'm tangled up.
And there's,
I guess the third issue too,
we just given that you have to value things in order to,
after that you have to act in what should you fail you and so,
and how is that related to tell you should perceive the world.
Okay,
so that's the kind of press,
the problem space,
let's say that we're going to investigate,
and this is related to chapter 10 which is beat precise in your speech was just
an attempt in 12 rules for life to lay some of this out.
So the first thing I want to point out is,
is some peculiarities of Oak.
We perceive the world.
So we can tell the story first about famous psychological experiment that was
run by Dan Simon.
I'm going to go through it pretty quickly.
It's an experiment that has to do with a phenomenal that Simon called changed
blindness.
I don't think he invented the term.
I think it's supervised but doesn't have it for our purposes or what Simon did.
He made this vision and most of you have seen it.
I'd take,
he put six people in front of an elevator in a psychology lab and uh,
he had three of them dressed in black,
300 dressed in wiping the black team,
Heather basketball.
And the white team had a basketball and the way team was sort of dance around
and passing the basketball back and forth.
So it was black team.
They had their own basketball and your job was coming to fill out,
sit down,
watch the video,
count the number of times with the white teeth through the basketball,
back and forth.
Now it's all you have to do now.
So you,
you go to magic committed your state of mind.
You do that.
So you've come to the lab,
you've come to participate in the scientific experiment,
you've come to following instructions,
and you've come at least in principle to demonstrate that you're capable of
doing all those things.
Right.
I'd be somewhat intimidating to come into the lab like that.
And you want to do a good job and maybe you want to do a good job because we
want to be a competent person.
And the reason I'm telling them all that it's because you've got to think about
why you would follow the instructions and you do.
Okay.
Because it turns out that the fact that you follow the instructions is very,
very important in this particular demonstration.
So you sit down in a video unfolds trying to do,
the people in the any org are quite large,
like they still the whole street so they're not way off in the distance.
That's important because what happens,
it's so Simon starts the video room rents for about three minutes and the white
team is wound around folks in the basketball and throwing it back and forth and
you're watching them and you're competent.
One,
two,
three,
four and safety.
You're doing a fine job and he'll turn into doing a fine job.
You run up the whole three minutes and have the extra vendor says,
how many times did the way teams are the basketball back and forth.
You say 16 and he says,
correct.
And he was thinking he great day stuff now.
So,
and then he says,
well,
can you see anything peculiar when you say
no,
what do you mean peculiar?
He says,
well,
did you see the gorilla?
Right?
And,
and you say,
well what do you mean?
Did I see the gorilla?
There was no gorilla.
And so Simon says,
okay,
watch the video again,
this type don't count.
Sort of rewinds it plays it like a minute into the video.
Three minute video.
This guy comes in front of the left of the screen,
he's like six foot four.
He has a girl,
a signal,
it walks right into the middle of the video,
right in the center and beats his chest for five seconds,
like gorillas,
do these type of things.
And then he saw Joe's office.
No,
got you.
Just as if it's a cross.
He was soldiers out of beaches chest quite confidently.
And then one just off to the side.
And about 60% of the people who watch that video don't see the grill.
And so some of you have watched that video and make you so the grill,
maybe you did it.
He,
that he made a follow up video for all those people who thought they'd learned
their lesson the first time they watched the video in this video.
The same thing happens except when the gorilla comes out.
Now people are crying for that.
Ain't that caps the grill,
the curtains behind changed from red to gold and one of the team players leaves.
And so,
you know,
he asks you to start retrieving all smart vote,
whether or not you're sewing things strange when you see the gorilla and he
rewinds it says,
yeah,
but you see the curt and change color.
But the curtain name,
not just the curve,
but that you missed that completely.
And it is the fact that someone left.
It's like,
so even when you know you're blind,
you're still blind.
And Simon's done stranger things to that.
So one of the experiments he did Harvard,
which is a great experiment,
is to put a camera on top of a building,
is building Hartford Yard,
which is,
uh,
the,
the basic central point from the campus.
And there's lots of people out there to have an undergraduate going up to a
tourist for the map and ask for directions.
Okay,
so now to undergraduate here,
tourists,
they're asking directions with the map.
Now over here,
there are two workmen and holding the door like this.
So here's the door.
It's can't see the word,
right?
Cause the door covers,
there's one at the front and one at the bat.
And so undergraduate tourist workman,
they walked right in between the tourist and the undergraduate.
And then the undergrounds,
if he's asking for directions,
grabs the door and keeps on walking.
And one of the work grabs the map of stands there.
So basically what he's done is swap people.
And both 60% of the tourists who were being asked for directions don't notice
that they're now talking to a different person.
Great.
So well.
So that's how blind you are and you,
you are a staggeringly blind.
It's amazing that you can make it in the world at all.
In fact,
most of what you've seen when you look at the road is actually your memory and
not the world.
Because your brain uses your memory of things to fill in what you don't see it
as we've already demonstrated because you didn't see the gorilla.
God only knows what you're missing.
And that's the critical issue with regards to that experiment is like who knows
what you're missing.
And the thing that's so crucial,
here's,
here's where value plays into it.
This is why maybe a case of you follow the instructions.
It's like,
well why didn't you see the gorilla announcer as well?
And you were counting the basketballs and the question is,
well why were you counting the basketballs?
And that's that is cause you were following instructions.
And then the question is,
well,
why are you following instructions?
Instead of paying attention,
let's say to the gorilla,
which seems more relevant and say,
well why were you following instructions anyways?
Well,
you're trying to be a good experimental subject.
I guess maybe you're trying not to look stupid,
you're trying to do the DAS property.
Why is that?
Well maybe you want to demonstrate that you're a competent person.
So like why is that so important to you?
You see,
the reason I'm asking all these questions is because the way that your
perception was structured in that experiment is dependent on all the values that
you brought to the perceptual act and experience.
All of those things work.
Focusing your attention on what it was that you focused on.
And that was the,
the balls and not the gorilla.
And so those are all issues of value.
The only reason that you've come to the ball if it was because you thought that
was the most important thing to do in that circumstance.
So that was what you valued above all else in that circumstance.
And so what that shows is that what you value determines what you see.
Now I should say,
I should just stand here and repeat that phrase to you for the next hour and
then leave.
Right?
Because that's so,
it's so important that it's so mind boggling that this experiment was a
bombshell in psychology for a whole bunch of reasons,
but it was also a popular bombshell because almost how many of you have seen
that video,
you know?
Yeah.
It was towards you,
right?
It's like how many other psychology experiment videos that you've watched?
Like zero.
This one,
everyone who's watched and now no other questions.
Have you watched the old by anyone ever,
and so that just shows you how I've seen the mind boggling.
This is almost not exactly,
it's not me.
It's so shocking.
It can be the case,
but it's actually even more shocking than just the revelation that you're blind
because that's bad.
Not because you think,
of course I'd seen the gap grill.
It's like,
no,
you go and buy.
But that isn't even a thing that's most my,
but what's most of the most mind boggling in it about it is that it was the best
illustration that psychologist had ever managed about in some sense about the
structure of perception.
But even more importantly about the fact that your perception is conditioned by
your values.
And so we're going to delve into that a little bit because the thing is,
what are the things you might ask yourself is
if you miss the gorilla,
we also use music.
And then you might ask yourself,
well,
are you missing something in your life?
And you know,
the answer to them is often yes.
And then the question arises,
well,
if you're missing something in your life,
maybe you're aiming at the wrong thing.
If you're valuing the wrong thing,
so you're blind to what you need.
And the world is very complicated place.
There's lots in it.
And if you're missing something important,
it might be because you're not eating,
you'd have the right thing.
Like,
and it really might be that.
That's the thing.
That's what they meant.
So deadly about that experiment.
Now that is the only thing that experiment isn't the only experiments that
experiment that demonstrates this sort of thing.
There's convergent evidence supporting this line of thinking for all sorts of
disparate areas of psychology,
psychology,
perception.
So,
um,
the first other piece of evidence is this.
You have the music,
perceptual resources.
And so especially for vision,
because vision is really,
really narrowly intensive.
So you mostly,
when you look at the world,
we mostly use the center of your eye.
It's called the fold the on and lets the high resolution part of your eye.
Now you know the difference between a high resolution and a low resolution
image.
A high resolution image has lots of Fiji on a low resolution image has less
detailed.
So if you look straight ahead,
electrify,
look at,
and maybe I'll look at you so I can see your face quite clear.
I know you have a face but I can't see it.
You,
you're just a blur.
You I can just see the fact that your face is like your shirt is dark.
I can't see you people at all.
I know you're there.
I can,
I'm not letting my eyes cream tonight really can't see you people at all either.
So my digital space is limited to about that much.
And the part,
the sharp enough to actually see a face is limited to your face.
Cause I can tell you have eyes,
especially if you move the,
because I'm pretty good at detecting motion in my periphery,
but I can't tell anything else about,
you can't really,
I think your shirts blue,
I think it is.
So anyways,
now each of the neurons,
each of the cells in the phobia,
which is the high resolution department connected to 10,000 cells in the primary
visual cortex.
And then they're connected to infinite numbers of cells,
virtually about that.
The reason I'm telling you that is because for the old tissue is neurally
expensive.
And so if I needed my whole visual field to be as high resolution as my phobia,
that I'd have to have a head like at ain't [inaudible] and that will be on doing
so.
Right?
So,
so what we do is we make the most of what we,
what we have and we'd Gardner eyes around all the time.
So we're just sticking around is around like now taking snapshots of things and
stitching them together very quickly and it gives us the illusion that we have
the complete field of vision.
It's not just an illusion,
you know,
because obviously you could walk across the street most of the time to be hit by
anything that's moving too quickly.
So it's suffice is to keep you alive.
But there's way less of that there that you think.
Now what I see in high resolution,
so what I using my valuable neurological resources for is what I decided is
important.
And you can tell what I decide is important by the fact that I knew looking at
it,
right?
I'm choosing to point by Isaac something of value.
Why else would I call it a point to my eyes there that the mere fact that I'm
doing that is also an indication that I organized my perception with a value
structure.
And here's something that's really cool about people is because we want to look
at what's valuable,
right?
That that just seems kind of obvious why you love what is valuable when you
could look at what's valuable.
So how do you ensure what's valuable?
Well,
sometimes through painful learning,
you learn what's going on,
what is it?
But with PE,
there's other tricks that we acquired.
Figure out what's valuable to Sosa.
Here's something cool about your eyes.
So you know,
you have a pupil and then you have an iris around that.
It's colorful and you have whites around that,
right?
But you're weird.
That rate,
because animals don't have that even higher priorities.
The ones that are most akin to us biologically,
they don't have that.
We do.
And the reason for that is I want to see when you point your eyes,
and if you're Irish to stepping out on a white background,
I can really tell who your eyes are pointed and were unbelievably good.
It's figuring out where people point their eyes.
Exactly.
When we interact with other people,
pretty much all you do is look at their eyes.
Now it is.
Oh yeah.
Cause we look at their whole face cause they're signaling emotions with the face
or returned to figure out what all these other people that were looking to our
opportunity.
But part of the reason,
part of the way that we figured out what they're up to is by inferring what they
think is valuable.
And the way that we infer what they think is valuable is by watching where they
point thrice.
And people are really good at pointing.
Like if I pointed something,
which is like an extension of my vision,
if you have any sense,
you don't look at my finger,
you look at what I'm pointing out.
Now an animal will look at your finger does.
It just doesn't get the whole,
there's something out there thing,
which is part of the reason [inaudible] can't speak because the pointing
gestures,
prototypical speech it means signifies an object of value in often that object
to go,
you would have a name.
So we point with our eyes or things of value.
You can track people like this.
So there's a famous site,
social psychological experiments,
kind of,
uh,
you know,
casual experiment.
So imagine that you're,
uh,
you're the experiment.
This was done protective to go and all you do is decided to stand on the corner
and look up like this.
It's on a busy street.
You know,
somebody walks by,
they're kind of thinking that you'll look at that because there were two vague,
you go and you just keep looking up.
May Look at you,
they look up and they look at you again.
They looked up when they think,
well,
unless there's something wrong with you,
it must be something not that it is.
Why would you be standing here looking at otherwise?
And so they feel that there must be something important up there.
And so then they'll look and they'll look at you to see what's going on.
And then of course there's two of you located now.
And so we're going to drop there must really be worth looking at.
And so then the next person will come around and look to it.
So you get a crowd crowded people.
So if you're bored one day and you're smoking,
smoking too much,
pause the [inaudible] experiment about recorder,
you know,
so but credit.
But there's something,
there's something deep about that too because this is how we infer the
motivation of other people.
This is how we understand that it as we figure out what the hell they're going
to app and that helps us even further value structure.
And if I can infer your values culture,
if I know what you find is important,
then I can read you as a simulation online,
biological platform and I can infer what you're thinking and feeling.
And that's how we understand each other.
That's how it works.
We actually do use avoidance and computational platform to run this run
simulations of other people and we do that by ensuring their value structure.
We do that,
but I got to get what they're looking like trying to go what they're looking at
by trying to understand what they think is important.
That's what you do with it moving,
right?
You go to a movie like what the hell are you doing in a movie anyways?
Well,
it's entertaining.
that's not the question.
The question is why is it entertaining?
Why is it so important that you align up at pay to watch it?
Like that's,
that's really we're thinking about because you know,
it's strange behavior.
He fight.
It's so useful to you that you find it intrinsically meaningful.
So much so that you'll pay for it.
Well,
unless what?
He would just put it your Thomas,
is it just like useless activity or eating something that board or you're doing
something important.
You're going to,
to what's essentially a literary,
uh,
what would you call literary experience because it's a story and you're locking
yourself on the protagonist and the other characters and you're adopting their
value structure and you're embodying that and you experience all the emotions
and all the motivations for no,
no,
no risk to yourself except the $14 that you pay to be admitted to the theater
and you gain all that experience vicarious.
And that's part of how you understand the world.
And we're doing that with each other all the time when it thinks we're trying to
do is to watch each other and figure out what support to the other person so
that we can figure out what they're up to so that we convert what support for us
so we can orient ourselves property in the world.
It's a crucial,
crucial importance.
It's partly why stories are so important to kids.
For example,
you could teach kids over anything with the story,
you know,
will come running up to you with a book and say,
read me a story.
We'd be a story,
maybe the same story 50 times what we're trying to understand it.
That's how important it is.
It's absolutely crucial and maybe it's crucial.
Some of you can,
you know,
you could distinguish the gorillas from them,
from the basketballs or something like that.
Okay.
So that's another piece of evidence that we use our value structures to perceive
the world.
So that's took pieces of evidence.
Here's another way of looking at it.
So,
um,
if I'm looking at this landscape,
let's say on what we see in front of me is going to depend on what I decide to
do.
So now it's not only what I see and this is where it gets a little bit more
sophisticated.
It's not only what I see,
it's what I experienced.
It's broader than perception.
And with experience I would say what motivates me and also what an experience
emotionally.
So here's a nice way of understanding emotions.
It's very simple way and have the relationship with perception.
So let's say I need to go over offstage on that side of the stage.
And so if I'm standing here,
I have a clear path right to the other side of the stage.
And that's actually going to have a small effect on mine because once I decided
that going to the other side of the stage is the valuable thing to do,
when I see a clear path in front of me that produces a little burst of positive
emotion.
And the reason for that is that people experience caused propulsion in
relationship to the likelihood that they're going to attain a value goal.
This is also something that's worth thinking about because you tend to think,
well,
you experienced cost promotion.
When you get something you want.
It's like,
well,
wait a second.
It's not so simple.
I mean,
let's say you want to have a promotion at work and so you get the promotion.
Maybe have a party booked out,
but what happens the next day?
It's like what?
You're nervous both,
right?
Because you're not going to be word.
Now you have these new responsibilities,
so it sounds like you're on cloud nine permanently,
or maybe you graduated from high school and you're happy about that,
but the next day then you've got a new set of problems.
The same if he graduates from university here,
whenever you hit a good milestone in your life,
it sounds like you're there and that's that.
It's so that that that pleasure in the attainment of a goal could be quite
fleeting because then you need another goal and even the fact that you need
another goal after hitting that goal to be a problem.
Like he might be depressed after graduating from high school cause you don't
know what to do next.
That happens to people all the time.
So it turns out technically that the form of positive emotion,
positive meaning that's more reliable than that is the positive emotion that's
associated with the feeling that you're retaining a valuable goal.
How that's worth thinking about too.
Because what it means is that if you want to the meaning of life that's
positively engaging,
then you have to be pursuing the valuable goal.
And so,
and then we can tie that back to the discussion at the beginning.
It's like what?
The way the world manifests itself to you depends on your aim.
Okay.
And then if you're going to experience positive emotions world,
you have to have a valuable aid.
And then there was a criminal,
they reach about June,
which is the more valuable your rating,
the more positive emotional experience.
While you're moving towards it.
And so with that would imply,
at least in part,
is you want to have the most valuable,
the impossible.
That's what it seems to me.
So then the question is,
well,
what's the most valuable?
A possible case.
So that's where we'll go next.
But,
but anyways,
one of the consequences of that,
even in the small and the microcosm that say is that if you see a clear pathway
to a partial goal,
that gives you that boost of positive emotion.
Now pause.
Depostion is also associated with the act of moving forward.
So that's how your emotions are tied to your voice.
So if you,
if you're pursuing something of value and you have positive emotion that you
have to pursue it,
you're moving ahead and you know,
that's what you're saying when someone says how you're doing and moving ahead in
life is that,
that's a positive thing to say,
right?
I'm kidding your hair.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a positive thing as well.
It's like climbing up a hill.
That's a positive thing as well.
So we know that approaching something moving forward is associated with positive
emotion stopping.
It's like that's what happens when something happens that you don't expect.
So you're moving head towards a goal and something you don't expect conference
or a threat to something dangerous.
You start that same anxiety.
Technically speaking,
anxiety stops because you get anxious when you don't know what's going on.
You get anxious.
What you don't know.
If the path in front of you is clear,
they want and you should stop because you don't know what's going to happen.
So that's,
and then,
and then to retreat,
that's associated say with escaping from pain.
So you basically have three modes of B move ahead.
It's pause.
If you stop and you get over there and that's,
that's your whole and structure.
And so if you see a pathway in front of you as clear,
it just something you valued,
they're not pushing the positive emotion and your staff,
he moved forward forthright and they,
now,
if I'm standing here,
essentially it's just a little more complicated because there are things in the
way,
and that's actually in some sense how I see them.
Obviously that's a chair and that's a little stool.
And you might say,
well,
that's what those things are.
It's like,
yeah,
he's not so simple.
Exactly what they are.
For me right now,
there's minor legal obstacles.
It in the pathway to my goal.
And so they're dinged with a little bit of negative emotion.
Now,
not too much because I know I can just do this,
right?
So I could solve the problem that those obstacles constituted so they don't
bother me very much.
One of the things that are being suggested to people is that it's become a bit
of a need is that you should clean up your room and that's caught on like what
the hell?
Why did that catch what everyone has told you about since you were like one?
So it's a funny thing,
but,
but there's deep reasons for it.
It's like
your room.
Let's say you're in your room,
I dunno.
We'll see.
Are Your two hours a day just for the sake of arguments and so that we can do a
little math there that says stupid mouth.
So that's 14 hours a week.
So that's,
that's one.
That's one day.
That's what they need in your life.
Footsie or wait for doing something that is mandatory 14 hours a day.
So it's one seventh of your life.
And so in a,
in a year,
that would be a what?
40 50 days,
two months.
You're in your own for two months every year.
So that's one seventh of your life.
And so it's all free to your room.
It's really one seventh of your life,
right?
You can think about it as a material place,
that human habit,
it is that.
But that's not all it is.
It's a place that your experience is localized for one seventh of your life.
And you might think,
well,
how you want that experience delayed.
So folks like,
well,
I didn't want the place to be like an unruly hellhole so,
so imagine that you have you things to do in there,
right?
You have things to do in their work to maybe of thinking to do.
Maybe you have to get dressed so you can present yourself to the world.
They get off to sleep.
I don't know.
Whatever it is.
If you're doing in your room,
maybe playing on your computer to communicate with people.
Let's assume some of that is useful.
You know so well how do you want to organize that?
And answer is you want to organize it beautifully and efficiently because if you
do that and a good proportion of the one seventh of your life that you're
spending in there,
there's going to be a bipolar.
And so if you organize that room,
at least it make it clean,
let's say that's the minimum starting place,
make it clean.
Then the pathway to all those things that you have to deal with,
that room that are important becomes clear.
And then when you walk into the room you're going to feel positive emotions,
that negative emotion,
you know this perfectly well,
you know you don't perfectly well.
I walked into your room,
there's your desk and there's a bunch of things until their stacks of paper and
you haven't booked out with for like three months and some of them are like
cats,
bills,
phone bills,
correspondence.
You haven't caught up with it.
God only knows what.
And some of those bills are like older than they should be.
You think those were just stacks of papers?
Of course they're not there.
They're not stacks of paper at all except for the most trivial sets.
You're still annoyed with yourself and so terrified of them and when you walk
into your room,
do you want me to book them?
Right?
You'll still,
you'll make a concerted effort not to look at your desk and if you,
if your room gets cluttered enough and if you get,
if your light's gets cluttered and outs and everything around you will be like
that.
It's all cabled up pathways to hell essentially distributed randomly Greeley
Rehab.
We really,
that serious hope is distributing sort of randomly through your house and then
tower quarterly.
You're going to have reasonable,
productive,
meaningful,
beautiful experience if that's how you set up your environment.
It's not your requirements,
it's an extension of you.
It's it can't think of it any more clearly than that.
So with a behavioral psychologists know perfectly well what going to take.
You could do.
If you want to get people to start organizing themselves mentally,
he's to do something like organize their desk,
right?
I mean,
I know some of you have idiosyncratically cluttered desks and you know where
everything is and that's your weird little style and maybe that works for you
all know,
probably mostly instructional aid station Bas,
but
you know,
yeah,
that's just,
that's just the way I do it.
It's like,
yeah,
but you know,
if you take a take a shot at organizing that,
making them pathways clear and things clear up the front of you and the
probability that when you walk into your room it's going to welcome.
You think,
well,
that's weird.
Wait,
you're looking at it,
the group create welcome you.
It's like,
really?
You've never been in a room that's Bosco t it's just has,
you're not paying any attention.
I'm sure there's any theme in this auditory who don't like certain rooms in
their house,
don't like going into them because God only knows what's in there.
You know when you could feel that emanating from those places.
Where do you store the hundred and 50,000 decisions that you should've made your
life that you didn't make in the forums have stacks of things that you should
have attended two years ago.
If you don't think that it has any effect on you and you've just dealt with your
senses to the point where you don't notice because certainly has an effect on
you and you might also think,
well maybe you what we want to clean up your room,
which is something you know you want to make it beautiful,
how it means something even greater and something I didn't write your voting
quotables life in product.
We'd be in the next book.
It's like you could take it to the next step.
You could normally set up your room so that you knew where your clothes were and
you knew why you were aware and you knew who you were going to be when you more
and you set up the place that you slate so that when you went to sleep you
slept.
So that B when you will come to the morning,
like you were refreshed and ready to take on the world.
So the whole place was pristine and it reflected your discipline and then you
could make the bloody place beautiful because you would learn how to do that.
You might take boats,
just my room.
It's like you're a wealthy man.
It hasn't been very long.
So it hasn't been very long at all in the history of the world that people have
their own room.
It's a bloody miracle that you have that.
And especially with the kind of rooms we have now,
and that's the case.
Even if you live in,
you know,
maybe the most talk,
the most desirable part of town,
you could still make that middle area that you're responsible for something
bloody pristine and perfect.
And that would teach you how to make a little corner of the world pristine and
perfect and that would help you be that way.
And then you being that way,
he be rude being that way with the ahead to your family.
Or they might have checked what nab and he'd say,
grow,
wake her up to it.
So,
and then maybe from there you can start to branch that out into the other things
that you're doing because these are not trivial issues there.
They're very,
very fundamental issues.
So to want to make your,
make your room that you would have the vast majority of the time into a
microcosm of the way that you would like things to be.
It's an unbelievably useful exercise.
What's so cool about it is you can just do it to practice right there in front
of you.
There's absolutely nothing stopping you except your contempt for what you have.
And that's something you should just dispense with entirely.
Because what's not helpful?
It's not helpful.
It's not accurate.
It's not psychologically useful.
It's,
it's counterproductive.
It's not good.
It's not.
We'll
only so,
so now let's,
let's,
let's go into this a bit more deeply.
So,
um,
one of the things I do with my students when I'm feeling like torturing is
asking why,
why,
why they're,
why they're in class.
For example,
say you're trying to do an assignment,
say,
well,
why do you care?
You do.
Usually you can get about five ounces of people with this line of questioning
before they run out of answers and then they're not happy that you keep
questioning it because it's rude.
It's like when you care about the assignment,
it's like,
well,
I need to hand in the assignment to get a good grade in the course.
Why do you care about what they not?
You get a good grade in the course.
Well,
I need to,
I need to finish off this year universe.
Oh,
I need to do that.
Well,
I need to graduate and and and have a degree.
why do you need to be fast?
And it's like,
well,
because I need to,
I need to get a job and support myself.
Well,
you get the basic idea.
Why do you need to do that as well?
I want to have a career.
Maybe I want to have a family.
It's like,
okay,
well why do you need to do that if you keep asking that question now,
now what?
I'm what I'm pointing out here is something that's sort of analogous to what I
was pointing out when I was unblinded.
Why you went to the lab to begin with and follow the instructions,
right?
There's a whole bunch of reasons that are determining your behave and so when
you do something like maybe you're going to a library and so we have to cross
the street.
If cross the street to the library,
when you have to get to the library to pick up a book and you have to pick up a
book to study and you need to study to pass the exam.
Then that nests inside all of those other plans that I just described.
So normally do you have a need,
let's say,
but you have a name that's nested inside of a bunch of other readers and so
that's how you focus your attention on the world is I need to cross the street
because I need to go to the library because I needed to get a book because I
need to study because I need to pass the exam because I need to pass the course
because I need to get the degree so it's like get a job so that I could take my
place in the community and what you,
what you notice is that with each of those questions,
the area that you're eating covers in terms of timing space,
that's the right way of thinking about gets bigger,
right?
Because crossing the street that's like the five second thing and going to the
library to get a bulk rate.
That's like a one hour thing and then study a one week they your cortices,
a one month thing or three months they are with each of those successive moves
out where outward you're describing a series of agents that cover a larger area
of space and time.
So you can think about that as your map of the space and time.
And that's a useful map because you live in space and time and so you should map
and that's what you do with your value structure because all of that's value,
right?
It's all assumption about what it is that's necessary to do.
So then the question is,
well what is it necessary to do?
How far out can you push that step up?
Assumptions.
It's like,
well it's kind of pushed it out to well I want to be a productive person who a
and I want to have a family take [inaudible] well maybe people stopped there
because they think at south,
but it's something like that.
It collapses into self evidence.
So it's rude bullshit.
It's like,
well it does.
It does.
Like what?
Cause you might ask,
well,
okay,
let's say you're going to have a career and a family.
Um,
is there a map in which that should be embedded?
And then the question would be,
one,
if you're going to have a career to a family,
how should you go about doing that in the best possible way?
Because I would be the next question.
At some point you're going to run out of ability to question.
You're going to hit hit the ultimate ends of the map.
I would say what seems to happen as far as I can tell is that when you get out
that far in the line of ethical questioning,
you start pictured that domain.
It's something like the story because if you don't have an explicit answer
anymore,
just say,
well I'm going to have a family and I couldn't have a career.
It was like,
well why are you going to do that?
Why is that an important thing to do?
Or how would you do that if you did it right?
And then when you do what,
at some point when you run out of explicit answers,
you start thinking about examples.
And you might think,
well that's where people have already always done it.
That's when people I admire hooked up.
No,
that's what,
that's what my father did.
That was what my grandfather did.
Or I knew,
I knew people who took real pride in their work and that's,
and that's how I want to conduct myself.
So you start to devolve,
what would you say your explicit precept position started to shout into
something like stories.
And so that's where our explicit knowledge meets the domain of the great story.
So what's the great story?
What's all that nested it?
This is where the discussion gets more complicated and this is where,
this is where it would have to dig to get this right.
Okay.
Have you tried to understand what it means to act ethically and all that?
Starting with the presupposition that that actually does mean something?
So you know,
in our modern world,
people tend towards a kind of moral relativism.
They make the proposition that there's many,
many ethical systems and it's very difficult to adjudicate between them.
And maybe there's no ethical system that has predominance over any other ethical
system.
Something like that.
But I don't buy that.
I don't think it's true at all.
I think that there's very limited number of ways that you could make your way
through the world properly,
and that that's severely constraints.
The value system that you have to a dog,
let's say.
Well,
if you want to,
do,
you want to be,
if you want to be a family and you want to do that properly,
let's say,
then how might you go about doing that?
Well,
let's see if we can,
we can take that apart and look a bit.
Uh,
I can use this as a,
as a means of,
of examples.
Okay.
You want to be a good father.
And so then imagine that one of the things for the good father does is teach his
children how to behave properly.
So that's rule number five in my book,
right?
Don't let your children do anything that makes you dislike them.
So I'm going to give you a sophisticated example about how you might teach your
children to behave properly.
And that would be part of the structure in which being a good parent would be
nested.
Okay.
So I'll tell you a little story about hockey game.
I've watched once was a cocky gate that my kid,
something was involved in it.
He was a pretty decent talked there and he was on the book 13 when this was
happening.
But he used to go watch him play at least those neighborhood lead and here's a
good hockey player.
But he wasn't the best talking to bear and his team.
There's this other kid that was clearly at the start and we were watching this,
the championship game and uh,
you know,
it was well if foc game between well-matched dinged.
So that's a good thing.
Right?
Generally if you want to watch a sports game,
weirdly enough,
do you want to see a well 14 between well-matched teams.
You don't want to see one team just stomp the hell out of the other,
you know,
and have the game be 18 to one it's not that sox fine.
Do you want to see the struggle?
I'm full and it been relatively matched manner.
It's kind of interesting because it's not obvious why you would want to see,
you know,
one team just,
beat to death,
so to speak by either,
maybe you could take some gratification in that,
but if you have any sense you don't,
you want to see the team struggle against each other.
You want the outcome to be,
to be too hard enough so that it's uncertain and you want to see the spectacle
unfold in real time.
And so that's what was happening.
So it was really good game.
And then in the last six,
seven seconds of the game,
real cliffhanger or something like that,
uh,
about six or seven seconds on the kids from the opposing team.
Zicam ice can't beautiful place or oppose goes the rent.
And that was the end of the game and everybody cloud.
But you know,
the kids lined up and shook each other's hands.
But the star on my son's team,
he was knocked out,
he was not happy.
He,
he was acting out the proposition that he had been wrong.
And so he got off the ice and he took his hockey stick and he smashed it up.
The spent them a little tantrum and old and uh,
which was pretty pathetic.
His father,
seriously.
That's like,
what the hell?
And so then as far as father came rushing up and his father was a preposterous
idea
and he basically agreed with this sub.
He said,
yeah,
you were abroad.
Did you played such as protection again,
you should one the referees took it away from you and you know,
he was just some misbehaved like two year old.
And then he rewarded for it and reinforced.
It's like,
well,
one of the things that we could hypothesize is that's not a good way to be a
good to be good parents for that matter is that in some manner he was damaging
his son and so,
and he paid for it.
It's like I didn't know the guy a bad dude.
I watched how he conducted himself of the chickens eventually came home to roost
as they inevitably do.
And so,
you know,
and so we'll keeps put what was the problem here?
Exactly.
It's,
it's not so easy to take apart.
So think about his son was,
he was the best player on the team.
So I mean,
he's trying to win the game because that's what you're supposed to do is
trigger.
But again,
if you're the best hockey player in the teapot,
that's a kind of victory,
right?
And if you're trying to win,
well that's what you should be doing.
And if you don't,
we have it.
Why not be upset about it?
Because after all,
what you're trying to do is win.
And so,
but,
but you know all of them.
No,
we've know what your weaker moments,
you might act like that kid's father,
you know,
you know that that's not good.
So why,
why,
what exactly is going on?
And you might say to your kid,
well,
it doesn't matter whether you win or lose your kindness over,
played the game.
And your kid thinks,
what do you mean by that?
And you say,
well,
I don't know,
but it's the right way to behave.
And it's like,
yeah,
you don't know,
but it is the right way to behave.
And so I can tell you why it's the right way to behave and think.
And so it just goes along with just chapter five.
But that your children do anything that makes you just like so,
so imagine this.
So what is it exactly that you're trying to do when you want your kid to win?
That's first of all,
you got to think about what do you need by when we were in decided to do,
you don't need stomp your entity,
a team to nothing on in the hockey arena because there's something about that.
It's just not exactly right.
Okay.
So,
uh,
what do you mean give me win this game?
Well,
no,
you don't exactly mean that because life is APP game,
right?
It's a sequence of kings and probably that it's a secrets of different games,
And realizing that you're going to be a pro hockey player,
just you're not,
so you might as well just give up go hat cause it's,
you know,
it's just not going to happen.
But even if it does happen,
it's still a sequence of games.
It's not one thing.
It's a sequence of change.
But if you're a typical person,
and even if you're a pro hockey player,
hockey is just one of the many games you come into play and you're going to play
those games with the same people often over and over and over and over.
And so then you might say,
well the rules that govern the probability that you'll win a set of games isn't
the same as the rule that governs whether or not you would one of you should
never compromise your ability to prevail in a set of games for the purpose of
winning a single game.
And so when you tell a kid should be a good sport,
Kevin,
what you're saying is
that was the game has a sequel haven has some important,
it's up to you to try and win cause you don't find the playbooks as he tried to
win.
But this case is only part of a much bigger thing and you're not trying to win
in this at the cost of the much bigger thing.
That would be foolish.
And so what you actually want to do is conduct yourself in the game in a variety
of ways that maximizes the value of the whole set.
So you might say,
well let's say you're on a team passed the damn pot now and then why?
Well,
cause you thought teammates and maybe your whole team would be better to help
develop them.
So,
and maybe you could be the star,
you should try to be the best player on the team,
but at the same time she did it the whole team better.
So you know,
spend 30% of your time passing the damn park to 700 kid.
So,
and then,
well,
you know,
that's also gonna show the other kids that year or someone who's worthy of,
of,
of being on the team.
That's a really important thing because you're going to be on the load of teams
and then as well,
if you conduct yourself properly while you're playing the game and people
observe them,
then they're going to invite you to play a bunch of other games.
And that's really what we want for your kids at school.
Right?
If you think about it,
you don't want them to be the best at a game.
You want the probability that people will invite them throughout their life to
play in a whole series of interesting games to be absolutely maximized because
then they'd never lacked opportunity that think the whole world opens itself up
to them.
It's so what you're saying when you say it doesn't have a human or lose it
matters how you played the game is conduct yourself so that you have the highest
probability of preventative cross,
the whitest possible set of gauge.
And there's an ethic there and there's a real ethic there.
It's real because it is really the case that life is a set of games,
uh,
a very large set of the cage.
And it really is the case that there's a way of playing a set of gauge that
maximizes the probability that you'll be successful at the largest number of
games.
And it's very,
it's a very sophisticated ethic.
It's like,
and so I think I can develop that a little bit.
It's like now you're trying to figure out how to conduct yourself in the world
are going back to what's the outside of the value structure.
How are you going to be a good parent?
You're going to teach your kid how to play properly world.
You have to know how to play properly in the world to do that.
So that's going to go along with it.
It's like,
well I'll,
how else might that outside,
uh,
ethical structure,
the parameterize that say,
well you want to play the game so that you take care of yourself because you
need to take care of herself or someone else has doing doesn't seem like a great
deal.
So you have to take care of yourself and that's hard.
You know,
there's things you need your complicated thing to propagate across time,
right?
So you have to take care of yourself,
but you have to take care of yourself in a way that works today.
It doesn't interfere with tomorrow.
And so the today and tomorrow don't interfere with the next week.
And so today,
tomorrow and next week don't interfere with next month and next year.
Cause you're not just taking care of yourself,
you're taking care of the set of your possible future selves.
And that's way more complicated and difficult.
And so you're parameterizing what you have to do.
He,
there's an ethic Amanda,
but it's more stringent than map because no man is an island this,
they say it.
So it isn't that you just have to take care of yourself,
take care of yourself and your family and you have to do that in a way so that
there's no interference between the two of you.
And so that it propagates across time.
So that's really difficult.
And then you have take care of yourself and your family in a way that absolutely
benefits the community.
And so that,
that makes it even harder.
And if there's no reason not to aim it out because we'd be talking about what it
is that you should aim at,
it's like,
well you might as well aim at that because there wasn't anything better that you
put a mat.
And we already decided that piece to some degree,
that the way the world manifests itself to you is dependent on what you,
a map and then you should aim at the best possible vein.
And so now we're trying to figure out what the best possible thing is.
There's a hypothesis there too,
which is the more you're willing to aim at the best possible fame,
the better the world that reveals itself to you is,
and you know,
you,
you kind of one of that,
I think you kind of know that already.
I would say part of the reason you know that implicitly,
you know that in the same way that you admire someone who's,
who's a good sport,
because you are,
that even if you watch pro,
if you watch pro sports,
of course inspiring people with skills,
there's no doubt about that and you should because they're supposed to develop
their skills.
But the athlete who's top form and who's,
uh,
who's,
what would you say?
Who's a mature,
an honorable player that goes to the people that shine above everyone else.
They have the skill,
but they have the nobility of character and you put those two things together
and you think,
well there's an APP.
There was a role model for young people as well,
so it's not just that they could play the game,
suffer badly.
Although the candidates that they blame the set of getting suffered and you
know,
you see that an athlete too who have a real well real stellar reputation,
let's say stellar like a star because that infers to starve course to start with
something that you have to lift up your eyes above the earth to see it,
to look.
I want it to have it into a transcendent space into something that twinkles in
the dark with the source of light to all of that managed is part of what you use
when you describe someone as a star and it's because you know placidly that
they're acting off his ethic.
That's part and parcel hopes at the world's straight.
So soul.
That's quite remarkable.
That's all equipment.
I think this is like me.
It's all standards at least to some degree out of the gorilla experiment,
right?
It's like,
why is it that you saw what you saw?
It depends on what you mean now.
It's like,
okay,
now that we've started figuring out that what we see and what we emotionally
experiences associated with what we aim at,
that we can start figuring out just exactly what we should email.
And so here's the kind of thought and I think it's a worthwhile one.
We'll do two things.
Well before this fight,
I didn't talk about how you can get your aim street.
Here's disappears.
So I thought a lot about the idea of meaning in life.
I wrote,
the first book I wrote was called maps of meaning.
Exactly.
There was an attempt to lay out the structure,
meaning as soon as that such a thing existed,
um,
I derived some propositions as a consequences of writing that book.
Um,
it's a very serious book.
It's all in audio form now.
Casey Richards did it came out about three days ago.
So it's a hard book,
but I think it's a lot easier to understand it.
It's spoken form because I could adequate proper intonations to the complex
sentences and Abimelech due to the,
to the right and so if you like 12 rules for life and if you're interested in
what I'm talking about tonight,
then you can give it a shot.
It's about 50 hours long.
I think that anything in the spoken for form,
so it's very demanding.
It'll take you places that are very much worth going.
Seriously,
please.
They,
they picked very much what's going on as far as I'm concerned.
I'd be basing the lectures that I'd be doing it for 30 years on that book and
the people that I brought along on the journey that constitutes the lecture and
seek to think that it's worthwhile as well.
So you could give it a shot and it's a study.
It's a study of the meeting.
There's a set of propositions in bedded in it.
One of the propositions is that life is intrinsically and erratic,
deeply meaningful,
but the ineradicable meaning is negative.
Like the suffering people are limited it mortal.
We all die like this.
Like let's go to a tragic element that there's no arguing your cell of,
and so when people say is life meaningful that it's what they need because the
negative part of life is right there and you're going to experience it whether
you believe it or not,
when you're stepping into a meeting or not,
that's nothing to do with whether or not you're going to suffer pain and be
anxious.
That's going to happen regardless of your rationalizations and so you're stuck
with that and you could consider that some sense of a fundamental reality.
And I would say most transcendent religious systems make exactly that claim.
So Judaism of course concentrates on the trash the past.
Now I'm going to say he says all these religious systems concentrate on one of
the first noble truth of Buddhism is that life is suffering.
And then of course there's Christianity and you are all familiar with the
central symbolic figure in Christianity,
which is the crucifix,
which is if that is the representation of suffering,
then then you're not paying attention to the religion because that's obviously
what it is.
In fact,
it's the worst time of suffering because here's the worst time of suffering.
He saw her physically,
mentally,
right,
but the reason you suffer is because people be traded you and they'd be training
despite the fact that you're in this.
So it probably is it suffering is the worst suffering,
which makes it architectural in some sense.
It makes it a kind of suffering that can't be exceeded.
So that that's why that simple has such,
it's one of many reasons that that symbol has such power.
It's like,
okay,
so that's the bottle of wine.
That's the baseline structure of reality.
Let's say.
God,
that's so pessimistic.
It's like,
yeah,
that's for sure.
But what is it is,
it's unbelievable to be pessimistic,
but,
but the thing is is that you can't get to what you need to get to until you get
to what you can barely tolerate.
That's a good way of thinking about it.
And you all know,
and I think part of the reasons perhaps that you're here is because I'd be
talking about these sorts of things in my lectures and my books,
and I'm not trying to pull any punches like I do believe that everyone knows
that the claim that life is suffering,
and then it's tainted by malevolence by the way in which even makes it worse,
right?
It's not just suffering.
It's not just the fact that life is tragic,
that's bad enough,
but it's made worse by the fact that no matter how bad things are,
or you can do something stupid to make them worse,
and he probably not only will it have you all know that because you know,
you know perfectly well that when you're miserable,
I mean,
I know terrible things could just sort of happen randomly and I understand that
perfectly well,
but you also know that many of the most miserable moments in your life,
no doubt there is many of them.
You are accompanied by this sense that you knew bloody well when you were
getting into it.
You weren't smart enough to stop it.
Or maybe you even facilitated or maybe facilitated knowing that suffering was
going to be,
they'll come and say,
well to hell with it,
I'm going to do it anyways.
And so,
and you know,
or maybe it'd be betrayed by someone cause that happens very often and maybe
you'd be traded some honor.
You aren't deceitfully or immorally by your own moral standards by the way.
And so nothing so bad that you can't make it worse.
Right?
And so it's not just that life is tragic and it's also touched with malevolence
and that definitely makes it work.
So,
so that's your starting point.
It's like,
okay,
so that's about,
I'm as pessimistic as it gets.
And you know,
you do read dealt into that you can look at,
I studied totalitarian brutality for 40 years I guess in Hawaii and I was
clinical psychologists,
just oil.
I still am.
But I've done thousands of hours of clinical work and I've seen some pretty
nasty things of course studies and things that were perhaps even worse.
And so it is definitely the case that people can make it the mirror tragedy of
their life.
And just something very much approximating hell.
Some of you probably from families have done exactly that.
Or maybe you're in a family right now that's doing exactly that.
It's like,
so in that step that takes a bad thing.
It makes it unbearable.
You know,
you've been thinking sometimes matching people around the deathbed that the
family member,
right?
And there's all sorts of unresolved family conflict.
And so isn't that not that the person's laying there gasping up their last
breath,
but everybody in the room was hostile.
And let's say they're also arguing because that's certainly a good time to have
an argument that it certainly happens.
Plenty of it.
So you can take stuff from that's pretty damn bad and then you could turn it
into hail.
And so that's life.
You think,
well that's pessimistic.
It's like,
yes,
good means we've got to the bottom of things.
That's a place that you could start building and say,
all right,
fair enough.
It's like life could be like that.
So what that means is that you need a reason to you.
You need a reason when things aren't good,
you need a reason to get out of bed in the morning.
You need a reason to move forward despite the fact that life is essentially
tragic and it's tainted by malevolence and the question is,
is there anything that's up sufficient?
Grand jury I'd say are sufficient.
Nobility were sufficient solidity to be of the 80 to you when you're facing with
the tragic malevolence of life and I think the answer to that is yes and that's
why this isn't pessimistic because if you could pose the worst possible question
but then you can answer it with the proper answer,
then the question is no longer so bad.
Carl,
you said instruct holiness in for the tour.
It's a Latin,
it means that which you most want and will be followed where you least want to
look man,
that's a smart idea and then actually happens to be wavering.
Look where your where was easy to look.
Yours is a book where you want it to look.
It's time to look where you don't want to look and that's that sweeping for
sure.
It's like,
well,
we just look where we don't want to look at this conversation at the darkest
part of life.
It's like,
well,
are we all do it?
If that's the fundamental preconditions of life,
yes it is.
Are we up to it?
Well,
the answer that seems to be yes,
as a matter of fact,
but no matter how difficult life is,
and no matter how tragic the conditions,
no matter even the fact that it's made worse by the malevolence of the human
spirit that say we're actually capable of moving forward and prevailing under
such circumstances with our eyes,
I would say,
well,
the world reveals itself team in accordance with your aims in the world.
So I can say,
well,
the world has this proclivity to tilt towards tragedy and malevolence.
What are you going to do with all the power?
You need the name.
But it's so remarkable that acting towards it justifies the catastrophe of your
existence.
And you know,
I could put that in pro se form.
And you all know this is true too.
You need a reason to get out of bed in the morning when things aren't good.
And things are in our thing to be good.
At some point,
you know you're,
there's going to be illness in your family.
There's going to be the collapse of your dreams.
There's going to be the pathology of your state is or you're going to,
you're going to encounter all the vicissitudes of life now just for sure,
and if your goal is to be happy,
well that's not going to get you through the rough times.
That's for sure because you're not going to be happy then and it's precisely
during the rough times that you need to get through and maybe you can say to
yourself something like a,
look what I'm doing instead is pursuing a noble.
The school like the possibly can see robot going to take care of myself
properly.
I'm going to do that in a way if it's a maybe a maximal benefit to my family and
aren't going to take care of myself and my family in a way that it's a valuable
benefit to my community.
I'm going to take all those things into account simultaneously.
And the reason I'm going to do that is because I can push back against the
tragedy of the world and I could constrain these malevolence.
I can do that in my own heart and I can help the people around and do that.
And you can in fact do that.
Certainly you could make it worse.
That's absolutely undeniable and that's actually a great place to start because
once you know that you can make it worse.
You know,
if these,
if you could see doing that well Brian,
well that's something,
right?
Even if you're not moving the world,
you know extraordinarily rapidly towards Heather do,
you could move it at least be somewhat quickly away from hell.
It gets the hell of it.
You're capable of producing and it's not right.
That's nothing cause you can cause a lot of trouble.
You have that firmly within your,
you have the power to cause a lot of trouble.
You know that because you probably already caused a lot of trouble now and then
and so you can at least stop doing that.
You could see that ability by looking at capacity for destruction,
you can see what you're capable of.
And so that should give you some respect for yourself and kind of a perverse
manner.
If you're that much of a force for catastrophe and managing what sort of course
for good you can be,
you might be enough of a force for good to stand up as a whole arc against the
catastrophe.
And I would say,
well,
so all that deep pessimism for me,
some sense disappears because I do look to people and I think man,
we got a rough,
like there's no doubt about it that this is available with tears and we could
twist it into something that's quite Hellige,
but there's enough nobility in each of us so that we can actually work against
that and we can,
we can make the world less tragic.
But he said we can definitely make it less bilevel in place.
And we did work on that,
like right in our local environments,
right?
We could make our rooms clean and beautiful.
We can make our,
our family's pristine.
We can,
we can get our age,
we can,
we can shut our aim and we can live in their eyes above the horizon aiming for
what's best.
We can do that.
And what's so fascinating about Catholics say,
well that immediately infuse your life with the kind of positive meaning that
they will sit down,
actually sustain the tragedy.
It's like I've done something worthwhile to do.
You know,
nature said he who has a why can bear any how.
I was like a brilliant phrase.
So you know,
one of the things are we doing is traveling.
Come to me now,
look,
I am here talking to people about exactly this,
talking to the promote them,
maximizing their responsibility.
They will because your life is tragic as authority lay notes.
It's like,
and so you need a way or viewing that with the richest possible meaning so that
you don't become corrupted and resentful,
angry and hostile and cruel and worse as a consequence of the burden that you
have to bear that's placed upon us.
But keep it.
Take that on Roland terror you can take,
well,
I wouldn't do absolutely everything I can to make absolutely everything around
me as good as I could possibly make and not some naive virtue signaling way.
That is what I need.
I mean to take this on like this,
the task of your life and it is the task of let your friend.
Then you think,
well,
what?
What would that make possible in this world of art school were remarkable
creatures.
You know,
we're all in a nice appeal.
We're on a night,
South Hill trajectory,
ethical,
you know,
things all over the world are getting better really quite quickly,
quite remarkably quickly.
You didn't know.
This isn't very well known because of our deep current pessimism.
You know,
people are being lifted out of poverty right now,
running the world and rape is absolutely unprecedented in the history of
mankind.
Ha.
We lifted half the people who were in absolute poverty in the year 2000 we're no
longer in absolute poverty by the year 2012 that was more than him.
[inaudible] 300,000 a thousand
people a week.
Right now or be hooked to the power group and people are getting access to fresh
water and the unprecedented rate and infant mortality rates are declining
precipitously all over the world and the world's fastest growing economies are
in sub Saharan Africa and no one is starving anywhere unless someone is trying
to start with to death because there's actually enough food for everyone and it
doesn't look like you're going to run out.
Our population's going to peak at about 9 billion and we can probably handle
that.
Especially given current growth rates in agricultural production.
You know,
it's so we did move into this future that lies in front of us,
especially with this technological prowess that would be developing.
That's absolutely remarkable.
We could,
we could move into this future and God only knows how much of the actual tragedy
of life we could push to the back of that.
How much is the malevolence that corrupts?
If he could obliterate,
who knows how good we could make things,
it would you think what your old bedroom and twisted because life is difficult.
If he'd betrayed like look,
fair enough,
man.
Life is difficult.
And you probably didn't leave the trade and what are you going to do?
I'm gonna make it worse.
Well,
that's not going to get you up in the morning,
right?
That's going to make you want to,
who knows what that's going to make you want to do.
It's not going to make you want to do something that's good,
that's for sure.
Instead you can say,
well,
bring it on.
Like I can handle it.
Keep it except for one that voluntarily.
That's rule one quite the way.
Stand up straight with your shoulders back.
That's the injunction.
It's like you can,
you can stand down and expose yourself to the catastrophe.
That's the world.
You could take that arm volunteerer as if there isn't,
if there's enough of you to manage it.
And the funny thing is,
the strange thing is,
is that,
and you know this already,
you know,
and if you're careful with yourself,
every time you take on additional responsibility,
you grow more terror,
right?
That's how life works.
You don't get to grow more character and strength without taking on the load.
You don't do that.
And then Jim Wright develop your musculature.
We felt pushing the amount of weight that you're lifting.
You can't just wish your apostles into growth.
They have to demand that they make themselves better.
Says,
oh,
your life is like that.
It's like,
well,
you have received calculable potential that people are always calling you on.
You're not living up to your protection.
You don't moving up to your potential.
You say that to yourself and other people say it too as well because they know
that he would hit you in some sense is the ability to take the entire
catastrophe of the world on your shoulders have to do everything you possibly
can to make it better.
And in that you find the meaning in life.
It makes all that to justify some of that tragedy that maybe what you making,
I don't know if it would make it desirable,
but it certainly makes it acceptable as a church,
you need the challenge and I think that the,
the possibilities that lay it open to us perhaps more now than at any point you
can pastor virtually without limit.
And you know,
I would say that we're recruiting things quite rapidly despite the fact that
we're actually stumbling forth for quite blindly.
You know,
we can be more alert,
more awake and more committed to the good.
We are substantially a garland.
He knows how much we did accelerate what we're doing and how good we can make
things.
And if you,
and if you're careful,
you could start that locally so you don't cause too much trouble,
you can just figure out what's wrong with you.
It just ask yourself,
you get a big list and then you can start working on it point by point by bit.
Say,
look,
I'm going to make tomorrow a little bit better than yesterday.
I'm going to do that iteratively get,
I'm going to do that every day and I'm going to see what happens if I use
everything at my disposal to push back against the catastrophe of the world.
Because maybe that would set things right.
And that's rule number six,
which is the one I'll close with.
Set your house in perfect order before you criticize the world.
And so
[inaudible]
what there is to,
you know,
and if you take on the responsibility,
if you take on responsibility for the fact that things aren't exactly how you
would want them to be and you've decided to important to begin to set them
right,
it's possible that you mold yourself across time into precisely the person who's
capable of doing that.
And why wouldn't you?
That that's how it works.
And so it seems perfectly reasonable that each of us could do that and god only
knows what would happen if we all did.
So it seems to me that it would be a lovely thing for all of us to try and it's
a good time in the history of,
of our,
of our species,
let's say for us to wake up and do precisely that.
So thank you.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
standing
up straight with your shoulders back.
Thank you.
Perfect.
A reasonable or I've been just a moment,
uh,
hopes of abusive in some questions over the Internet.
We'll come back,
we'll have a seat.
We'll go into some of your questions.
We'll do about 30 minutes of Q and.
A.
Uh,
it has is going to be wonderful.
And then we have,
this is like the,
I don't know,
those 16th showing this tour in every night.
Every lecture is different,
is just if you'd like to visit us again and we've got to,
we're in the Minneapolis,
uh,
tomorrow night in Milwaukee,
Minneapolis up and then a west coast swing.
And then we go a Canva in July.
So please feel free to join us again for another lecture,
Dr. Peterson and be out here shortly.
And this is,
uh,
this is really a movement.
I think it's really,
it feels wonderful,
but you guys are here to z.
[inaudible]
are you guys ready for the Q and a
great job.
Okay,
so here's a question.
We'll start with this one.
Are you aware that today,
yes,
today is national law or day [inaudible] no.
No.
I wasn't aware of [inaudible].
Okay.
So that's pretty damn funny.
So here's another thing.
Get this at all.
This is quite the street.
So are we trying to group how to tie a Windsor Knot in my tie?
And so I just started that like two days ago because I have this pit and tie
that does look quite pregnant,
total wins or not.
And then there's a question here that's,
that'd be just trying to understand why the world was,
have you thought about switching to the full Windsor?
Yes.
[inaudible] I don't know what in the world to,
to,
she knows what to do about that,
that's for sure.
Okay.
Um,
you've accumulated fade so quickly over the last few years.
You keep yourself humble.
And then there's some other questions like,
which is quite similar,
which is,
um,
where do you do to protect yourself from corruption since being put on a
pedestal?
What can do in the same situation?
Wow.
Okay.
So let's,
let's answer those.
Uh,
well,
I do these sorts of things that I was talking about to you today.
You know,
I have an eight,
let's say that I've thought through very deeply,
I mean,
when I wrote my first book,
which I told you about,
and I hope you have version maps,
VT,
um,
I thought about what happened in Auschwitz.
I thought about it from the perspective of a perpetrator,
not from the perspective of a bystander or a victim.
Let's say.
I thought,
how is it that people could do what was done in Auschwitz by the guards?
But I thought hope that more specifically I thought,
how is it that that person who is human could do that given that I'm also human
and I can't see how I could do that.
And then I thought about until I could figure out how we could do it
and so,
and then I figured out that I could do,
then I figured out that I could probably enjoy it.
And so that scared me enough so that I figured out that I tried to see what the
answer to that one,
you know,
up as far away as possible.
And so I would say that part of what I do to keep my feet on the ground,
which I written for the offense,
capacity for evil,
that every single one of us is characterized by,
and I terrified enough with that,
that say to try to Orient Myself property in the world,
say that fear of God is the beginning of quiz.
That's a good way of thinking about,
you could say
people conceptualize let's say,
because if you want to keep yourself on the up and up,
it's one thing to be ab for heaven,
but it's another thing to be a big weights.
And I don't care how cynical you are,
you can be cynical enough so that you don't believe in heaven.
There's no way you can be cynical enough so that you don't believe in hell.
And so once I've established that if you have any sense of the hall,
then at least you could aim away from that.
And if that's what you're doing and you know how deep that place where he is,
then that can help you keep your feet on the ground.
That's what it looks up to me.
So that's one of the answers.
I try to eat as far away from that as possible.
So that's part of what I laid up tonight.
Just like what am I trying to do?
Well,
I have my flaws and so no,
I'm not doing this perfectly,
but I'm dancing.
I'm trying to aim a week from that.
Tried to take care of herself,
trying to take care of herself in a way that is maximally beneficial to buy
salmon.
And I'm trying to do both of them was in a way that's maximally beneficial to
the community.
That's what I'm trying to do with.
The reason I'm trying to do that is partly because that's the best way a wave
from hell sort of.
That's a pretty good start.
But I also feeling that because I can't think of anything better possibly to do.
And so it's a immense challenge to do that.
And you need a challenge,
right?
And so why not have that as a challenge?
And I've talked these things through.
They're not shallow commitments.
That doesn't mean that I'm with error right there.
So then the other thing that you have to do,
if you want to stop yourself for big,
corrupt it is you want to surround yourself with the right people.
I know rule wonders stamp at straight with your shoulders back rule to it's
treat yourself like you're someone you're responsible for helping.
And we're all three years,
make friends with the people who want the best for him.
And those aren't injunctions about how to have a happier life there.
Injunctions about how to act morally in the world.
You need to take care of yourself like you're someone who's worthwhile and you
need to have people around you view you in the same way.
That doesn't mean they're letting you off the hook.
Quite the contrary.
And so I'm fortunate,
I have two kids,
they're both very sensible and their eyes are open and they're watching what I'm
doing and if I make a mistake or they don't make a mistake or not be cautious
enough,
they telling me why something takes away my Twitter password all the time.
Yeah,
yeah,
no.
And you know,
I can get it back,
reset the password,
but it's how you relate to him too.
You know.
So I don't like traveling with my wife and she keeps an eye on me.
She's,
she's always in the crowd and she sees what's happening.
She's a sensible person that she's picked tempered in your own inner fire.
So she watches and then I have friends around me and an extended family and
they're all watching and they are not hesitate.
They don't hesitate at all to do,
let me know if they think that what I'm doing is working.
But if it's not working and they take our greatest mistake,
it's like we have a phone call and they told me exactly what they think I did
wrong and how are we going to fix it and how you listen.
Because I don't want to do any more things wrong than absolutely necessary.
And so I would say part of the reasons that I keep my feet on the ground,
cause I hate to say I keep myself humble because I don't want to claim that,
but I'm trying to keep my feet on the ground.
Is because I'm properly terrified of doing things wrong.
And so I'd do my best to be very careful about what I say,
what I do,
and so far that has produced any catastrophic consequences.
So parades of that.
So,
okay,
well
this is very serious.
I don't know if I should address it because I was somewhat tired,
but I'll give it a shot because it's important how it's very serious troubles.
I plan on taking my own lights very soon.
Why it should?
Well,
I'm going to sit.
This is a casual request,
you know,
let's be put out for the purposes of display.
Well,
the first thing I would say is you have to think very carefully through the
consequences of that for other people.
So I've had clients in my clinical practice with never recovered from the
suicide of her family member decades later.
They were still torturing yourself above it.
And so that's what you leave behind.
Now,
problem is you might be dreaming.
Maybe you're feeling like this big twist is against you and that people deserve
to suffer for the misery that they imposed upon you.
That I would say think very,
very carefully before you pull down that route.
It's a terrible thing to leave people with and so part of the reason that
suicide has legal legally post societies is because it absolutely devastates the
people you leave behind and you might take what made,
you know,
if you're really depressed,
maybe you're really depressed.
That's a possibility.
He might take all those people would be better off without me.
It's like it makes you get really depressed,
you fatigue that way we can even get to the point where you can't think any
other way that and would say if you're at the point where you can't think any
other way than that,
that you should tell someone and you should go to the hospital because that can
happen.
It can happen if you get depressed.
There are treatments for depression,
you know,
and many of them work for some people,
antidepressants,
work Matt out that don't work for everyone and not claiming that they're a
panacea,
but they certainly beat the hell out of suicide.
Right.
Even if they have some negative side effects and sometimes they do quite
frequently they do.
The negative side effects aren't fatal.
It's like well are certainly there's a possibility that that that your condition
is physical,
that you're ill in some way,
either physically or perhaps you have a psychological problem and maybe you were
hurt her or,
I mean there's lots of reasons that people get depressed that are very,
very complex.
I would say don't give up hope without,
don't give up hope and do something fine up before you've explored all possible
the auctions and if you haven't talked to a psychologist,
you haven't talked to a psychiatrist,
you have to try and antidepressants you haven't revealed to your family or
people that care for you that this is how you're feeling.
Then you owe it to yourself and them to explore every possible avenue before you
take such a step and then you don't want to deprive the world of who I've of
what you could bring to the world.
That's the other thing.
You know you have intrinsic value and you can't just cash.
We couldn't have to an end.
You leave a hole in the fabric of be itself.
So you know,
and why is that that I once worked with Sam,
he was a very strange person.
He was a psychologist,
have to admit maximum security prison and Edmonton.
And I worked with him for a while,
briefly,
very briefly up the prison itself.
And he said,
you can always commit suicide tomorrow.
And that's a very,
like,
it's a flippant statement in some sense,
but he meant it in a very serious way.
It's like you only get to decide that once and you can put it off.
So I would say just put it off and then put it off score and then put it off
some more and see what you can do to put yourself together.
You don't explore every possible option.
And if,
if you're,
if you're so hopeless that you have a suicidal plan,
which is a real sign of danger.
If you really know how you do it,
you've thought about denim and say,
tell someone for God's sake,
tell them at or goil hospital and tell them.
And for sure trying to depress.
It's like,
what the hell do you have to lose?
So do everything you possibly can to address the issue before you do something
like that.
Do give some thought to the people that you're going to leave behind.
Because believe me,
you may just absolutely wait for the moment,
the way that they will never recover from it.
You cannot fix someone's suicide.
You're stuck with it and you think you torture yourself from the rest of your
life.
If I would have only known if I would have only said something different,
this particular talked to her,
her relative,
a sibling who committed suicide like 20 minutes before he committed suicide
probably after he took the pills and she was kind of preoccupied because he
don't know that the person at the other end,
because at the end of their Kevin and she never forgave yourself from how it
respond.
Big Property in that last phone call,
that's a hell of a thing.
Delete someone with,
so I would say of the final thing I would say is don't be so sure that your life
is yours to take.
You know,
you don't own yourself the way that you own an object,
you have a moral obligation to yourself as a,
as a locus of divine value.
Let's say.
You can treat that counseling,
that's theirs,
it's wrong.
So those are the reasons.
Exploring everything you can explore to put yourself back on your feet,
all the things.
There's all sorts of treatments for depression.
Don't leave the people around you with that to suffer for the rest of the Lux.
Don't underestimate your value in the world at don't underestimate the fact that
suicide is broad.
And so those are four reasons why you should end your life soon or at all for
that.
So good luck.
[inaudible]
I am the harvest at Herron art school.
What's your advice for young artists trying to shatter the conventions of
political correctness?
Well,
the first one that we probably get the hell out of art school
[inaudible] that's actually fairly
fairly straight forward if you want to shatter the conventions of political
correctness,
which is,
I don't take any field has been warped or thoroughly that fine art.
Quite quite political correctness,
you know,
so,
and that's really saying something because plenty of fields if the lenti work,
but I would say your best,
your best bet is two fold.
One is learn how to manage your career in effective business,
like manner,
make yourself come through in terms of putting yourself together economically.
Because if you're going to be really,
really,
really hard to monetize statistic production.
And so if you're going to support yourself being an artist,
you better be a sharp is this person.
There's nothing that irritates political correct people more than that in that
development.
So you could start by that.
It's like develop yourself into a cabinet negotiator and see if you could figure
out how you could actually have a career as an artist.
I would say to begin with,
what you're probably going to have to do is have an actual job and do your art
art time because,
and let us your fed globally tell it to that even that it probably won't work.
So you could even have the jaw and then you could work really hard on your art.
And with any luck over the period of about a decade,
you can build connection that works.
If you could learn how the gallery system works and you could be influential
people and you can sell your art,
maybe you could start to figure out how to make a living.
You got to figure it out.
It's going to take like 25 30% of your client at an absence and then you might
totally agreed with that and that'll irritate the hell out with your politically
correct Coles.
So because they'll say you sold out and people who say that those are,
we never have the opportunity to sell out,
justify that absolute moral respectability.
So it's an appalling gate.
The other thing you can do is study great artists throughout history and then
hone your craft because there's this idea of it's sort of a postmodern idea
that,
well,
it's all freedom of expression.
You don't need any skill.
It's like that's,
that's not,
that's not wrong.
It's like anti true.
It's not just an error.
It's like,
you know what the truth is it then you figure out the exact opposite of that and
put that forward as a proposition.
It's like develop your skill,
you know,
they're the pain to draw the scope to things and graphics person.
All these things develop your skill and then,
and your discipline as well.
And then maybe you'll be able to transcend that discipline with the skill and
produce something truly original.
But you could make yourself,
you could master the techniques of the great artists of the past and you know,
the,
the trending types to say,
well that's all past set.
It's like,
it's not nearly as passe as their demo opinions are going to be 10 years from
now.
Wow.
Started
an interesting guy.
You can find him on Youtube.
His name is Jonathan powershell and he's,
he was,
he was in an art school like you at a place called [inaudible],
which is like mind boggling late politically correct.
He was actually a pretty good postmodernist score.
It is.
Right.
And he got completely tired of the political correctness that characterize the
art schools and he became a medieval carver of orthodox icons.
That was his,
his reaction against the,
you know the training,
political politically correct orthodox and he makes absolutely beautiful pieces.
They're worth taking a look at,
so that was Jonathan how now when he's making youtube videos about syphilis,
Christian art that are really,
really quite good.
He's actually making a living doing that way too.
That's so funny.
It's like,
imagine how are we there yet?
Was is that there were firsties Canadian.
Then second of all cigarettes,
if I'm liking it to get the second is that he's making a living talking about
carving Orthodox Christian icons.
It's like no one will ever make a living doing that.
Know he decided that he was going to do exactly what you want to do,
which you don't want to shatter the conventions of political correctness.
You want to be an artist and if you are an artist,
see an artist is also someone who an artist is someone who produces art.
It's like that's a big mistake.
And artist is someone who uses our as a tool to investigate the structure of
reality and to extend the human capacity to perceive.
That's where the harm ducks and artists
really,
really grieving [inaudible] skill
so that you can extend the limits of the human relationship with beauty and
truth.
And you can transform the manner in which people perceive so that they can see
beauty when they only soft memory before.
That's what you want to do.
And if you do that,
then you were an artist.
Feel shatter,
all sorts of conventions in the post.
And you know,
you don't want to just set out to shatter convention.
That's like breaking the store window.
Anybody can do that.
You want to,
you want to replace them with a better set of conventions.
That's,
that's the right way of transcending one's conventions.
And you can do that if you,
if you discipline yourself and to be the true artist.
Let me tell you some things about true artists cause it's no joke.
So here's thing number one.
So Johann Johann Sebastian Bach,
first of all,
there's about five composers that dominate the classical music world and they
own these five that's now compared to all the composers who've ever lived.
And there their works composable half the classical repertoire and only a tiny
proportion of the works that they wrote our plate.
And so let's talk about bar,
cause he's one of the five,
he wrote so much music that it would take someone 40 years just to copy it by
hand if they worked eight hour cases.
Okay,
so just think about that.
Now let's talk about a castle.
Think how many pieces of how many paintings,
sculptures,
other objects of art didn't because of produce.
Well,
let's see,
he had a 70 year career,
65,000 he produced three fully form pieces of art a day for 65 years every
single day.
So it's just an,
you think about the Cuban of value of this production,
it's like,
it's like the Cuban revalue value quick and GDP of a decent size country.
It's absolutely,
really,
it's absolutely phenomenal.
And so if you want to be an artist and you've got big shoes to fill,
you want to,
it's,
it's the hardest thing to be and you have to be unbelievably disciplined at
attemptive,
ACC oriented and exploratory and courageous,
all of that at sharp on fronts to be an artist that you won't have to worry
about the conventions of political correctness because those people will be so
far behind you that you want to be able to see the bedroom door so
[inaudible].
When will the Biblical Series Lecture Series Continue?
December
[inaudible]
good.
I did ask you,
we just rent a small theater in Toronto.
What I'm going to start doing the,
the stories of Moses,
the exodus story is and so forth and I'm really looking forward to that.
I have a sneaky suspicion that there isn't anything more important that I can do
then to continue with those biblical lectures,
but I mean this is good to go around and talk to people.
This is a really good thing.
Great,
great.
Now,
but I think it over any reasonable amount of time,
right?
We have full off to continue to pursue that.
Partly because there seems to be a real demand for it who were new gas.
So preposterous.
It's even worse.
The Jonathan Passion situation is concerned
and I learned an unbelievable amount of doing it.
So I'm really looking forward to starting it up again.
So if the plan right now is to do that December and so,
so well,
so that's,
that's the answer.
That question.
So how can we be sure that we are not in cold?
I don't know about you.
Okay.
Convince me please.
No,
no.
Like look,
there are where there are ways you know that you're in a cold
call just and just some little system of belief or something like that.
Call it.
Does it called when there are people who study colts,
they sorted the assignment.
Maybe one is a cold leader,
a chief from your family and friends.
Because one of the rules of the in a cold is you don't get to associate with
anyone who is getting the cold.
Okay.
So are you being alienated from your faculty and ceramics
or maybe you're giving that to yourself.
That's your brother.
So,
so if you're speaking about,
you know,
paying attention to what I've been saying,
I haven't told you to alienate yourself from your family and friends.
I told him,
you get your bloody act together so that you're good for your family and your
friends.
That's like the opposite of a call.
[inaudible] the
next thing is the coal of Coleen and takes all your time and money.
I haven't taken all your money and I have taken all your time with three primary
dimensions of call time batting zero.
So,
so,
so it's,
it's ridiculous.
It's a ridiculous,
I mean understand the comparison because obviously there's something about this
set of ideas that has a compounding nature of some manner.
You have every reason to be skeptical and Leery of that.
You know,
when I tell my students at the beginning of point maps or maybe quarters that
they should do everything they possibly can to fight everything they possibly
can wrong about what I tell him,
that's their job.
So listen,
tell me,
because if it's wrong,
I'd like to fix it.
And so,
so I don't think that a call can be built on,
um,
a message of fundamental individual responsibility.
I think that's it.
You think it's a bit cold of individuals?
Well,
so it's good that you're skeptical.
It's good that you're asking that question but,
but the code comparison isn't,
is the good one because what for the reasons I just said the course does it as
well.
Is there reason to be skeptical of the ideas that are putting forth?
And I would say,
well of course there is.
You should be scared.
People have ideas.
But I would also say you should give some consideration for the fact that these
aren't precise and it's by ideas.
You know,
what I be trying to do is aggregate a set of great ideas that [inaudible] that'd
be,
what would it be?
They'd been handed down historically.
Some of them,
it'll be discovered scientific again to try to present those in a compelling
form to put old wine in new bottles,
let's say.
But you of course you want to be skeptical about that at watchful time.
We,
but that doesn't mean that it's a colt and it doesn't mean necessarily that
there's any intrinsic page.
I guess the other thing that you want to figure out is they say part of their
fruits,
you shall know that that's the statement in the New Testament is like if you've
been listening to these lectures and you keep putting the principles into
practice,
you can develop a vision for your own life and taking more responsibility and
trying to tell the truth.
What's the consequence of that?
Like when people talk to me all the time,
he said,
what things are better for me?
It's like,
well good if they're better for you.
Maybe they're a for you and your staff,
the better for you and the people you have intimate relationships with.
It's like,
that's good,
that's good.
That's a good diagnostic diagnostic indicator.
If you try out the ideas and they make things better,
then well that seems to be good piece of evidence and that's what I would watch
for and you could make up your own mind.
Stay skeptical whether you're doing it.
So,
okay,
why are you,
does message maybe
resonate with white people?
Okay.
There's no evidence for that so well,
so it's not a question the answer properly.
Zachary ticket's gone,
we'd question that's not posed problem.
What's your evidence that it does
to make a question like that,
which is actually kind of act.
You say you should get in in short packs.
Like it's just like what's your evidence for that?
So you don't have any evidence then?
What do you mean mainly exactly cause we're going to be exactly about this.
It's like there's probably a black person out here.
It's like what are you gonna do?
Go back.
Nope,
that's not a good question.
[inaudible]
what do you think is the great risk threat towards Western society?
Your unresolved weaknesses of the errors?
Most
I need that particular,
it's like the waste is predicated on the idea of the divinity of the individual
and that's mostly associated with individual responsibility.
And so to the degree that you abdicate that responsibility,
you're the threat.
It's as simple as that.
[inaudible]
is the corner for sustainable long term.
No,
I suspect that sometime in the next 50 years I'm going to die.
Okay.
You say it would take you 3.5 more years?
I don't think it was that precise to answer the question of Christianity Slash
God.
Slash Jesus.
Is this an honest answer out of respect or a non answer?
Well,
it's,
it's a vague gas,
first of all.
Maybe
there's lots of things that I have to prepared myself properly to talk about and
I'm,
I'm making,
making my way through these biblical lectures.
I don't know how far I'll get with them because God only knows what happens in
lights,
but I can't answer questions that I don't want how to answer and so it is an
honest answer is out of respect.
No,
it's sounding great condition perhaps,
but mostly it's on the recognition of my homie,
you know,
with the things that they talked to you about tonight.
I understand.
I understand that completely because no one understands anything completely.
I feel like I'm on solid ground.
W W with regards to what I talked to you tonight,
like I know the literature on perception well enough to tell you about it and to
tell you about how that's related to emotions and motivation and to,
to lay out the relationship between value and perception and all of that.
Because I've done the work,
you know,
I've read the papers,
I've written in the papers for that,
proud,
I've done the work and so I'm on solid ground,
but there's lots of things that exceed my capacity.
You know,
I'm,
I,
I do believe that are,
you know,
I,
I believe that our functional,
highly functional Western societies are grounded in the Judeo Christian ethic.
And then fundamentally that's a religious effort and that it makes a number of
metaphysical claims.
So I have great respect for the ethic and for the stories,
but I'm unable to assess the metaphysical claims.
And the reason for that is I ate urine.
I just don't know enough.
I don't understand the wellhouse way with regard to the idea of the death and
resurrection of Christ.
Like I deemed that psychologically and symbolically.
But that doesn't mean that I think that exhausts the store cause I don't believe
that my knowledge exhaust the story.
But I believe,
for example,
that the part of you that's capable of transcending tragedy and malevolence is
the part that dies.
It is reborn.
You have to leave the corrupt parts of yourself behind.
You have to let those burn off and you have to let your spirit be renewed
continually.
And that's an ancient story.
And I think that that has affinity with the idea of the dying and resurrected.
See now I don't think that exhausts the idea,
but that's as far as I've been able to push it.
I mean in my wildest moments,
and this is speculation,
right?
This is speculation.
I think the idea that Christ died for our sins and that mankind was redeemed is
correct,
but we still have to do the work.
It's something like that.
Now that's a benefit statement and I don't understand the whole,
right,
right.
Because I'm talking about things that no one can know of in some sense.
But when I pushed myself up to the limits of my knowledge and ask,
that's the sort of answer that comes to me.
It's like there is something about the idea of the,
of the individual sacrificing himself for that.
So we're taking the sins of mankind to himself.
There's a written that's real idea.
I think that that's what people shouldn't do is that in some senses that you're
responsible for the catastrophe of the world.
I believe that.
And I also believe that taking that one the fullest possible way,
we transform you beyond recognition.
And I don't know what the ultimate limit of that is because you could say that
the story of the death and resurrection is a living story.
Like the story of the crucifixion.
The crucifixion is suffering that can't be exceeded in some sense because it's
the most possible suffering for the most innocent possible person.
So that's the perfect tragedy,
right?
And so there's an idea that whenever Christ is,
is that which takes on the tragedy of the world in that which confronts
malevolence and overcomes it.
And I I,
that's the story of Christ.
The dessert,
for example,
the account per se,
and the story that Risa fiction is the willingness to bear that catastrophe of
existence voluntary.
And there's an idea that doing that produces a kind of transfiguration.
And I think that that's all true,
but I don't know what the limits of that truth are and sort of pushing it as far
as I possibly can within that domain acquired them.
It didn't understand me,
but I can't push it past that.
And so I know I have 300 books stacked up at home that I need to read.
You know,
the people that be sending me to get through this more deeply than I have been
able to get through it so far.
It's so it's,
it's recognition of my ignorance and it's respect for the complexity of the
problem.
And I said,
well,
three,
three years or four years,
that was just an estimate based on how quickly I'd be going through the paper
called stories.
But God only knows if I get any deeper into it than I've already been able to
find out.
So that's my answer I guess.
Oh,
good.
A behavioral therapy seems to be the most widely implemented theoretical
orientation in our practice and clinical practice.
What's your primary modality in therapy with clients?
I behaviors you get with,
because I look for simple solutions.
It's like,
well,
let's see,
before we get old psychoanalytic on people let me,
he wanted,
he wanted to save that and the union stuff for,
for exceptional circumstances as far as I'm concerned.
If a client comes to me,
you know,
here's the situation.
Someone comes to me and uh,
it's because their life is going the way that it needs to go.
Otherwise they would be there.
And so I think walnuts decompose the problem.
Why are you,
what happened?
What,
what?
What does your unhappiness system?
So that would take a lot of conversation.
That's the diagnosis.
It's like,
well,
do you have a good friends?
How are you doing with your family?
How's your career going?
Are you are attended to your education or you attended to your mental and
physical health?
Do you have a productive and useful use for your time outside of work?
And Are you swamped quite temptations like drug and alcohol use or sexual
misbehavior?
It's good way of deconstructing.
It's like how are you doing on all those dimensions?
If you do mind future authoring program,
by the way,
which is part of this so far,
three suite,
then it will ask you all locals questions.
And so if you want to do it,
I made a discount for all of you.
He could use a cold call,
12 rules that would knock the price down by 50% just so you know.
But we tried to,
I tried to put the essence of useful behavioral clinic,
Ricardo Behavioral Technical Practices to,
you know,
an exercise that people can do on the wrong.
So I want to find out exactly what is your problem as far as your concern.
And then when we want to be respectful at the simplest possible solutions.
And so I start from the bar.
Simple solutions,
right?
So like,
oh,
maybe you badly only shape physically and that's contributing to your
compression.
So,
okay,
how much exercise do you do?
I'll get you to track that for a week.
Don't change anything.
Just to see how much walking you do.
So I call,
I have walked like half a mile this week.
It's like,
okay,
well how about next week?
You try walking six tenths of a mile,
right?
Incremental,
small,
incremental behavioral groups.
It's a very straightforward way to help people and it's a pretty useful way and
you should try the simplest possible way.
And that's why I like the behavioral approach.
Now I have clients,
usually the ones who are creative,
who also benefit tremendously from UV and approach more symbolic approach.
They are often people dream a tremendous and who are creative in their,
from their essence and our use that when it's appropriate and necessary.
But that's,
that's rare.
So this is very noisy,
this thing.
So like me,
I guess.
So,
um,
let's see.
Uh,
now this could be the loudest one because I have to stop at some point.
Um,
do you have any advice for students studying psychology?
Yes.
Go to my website.
Yeah.
Reading list there of the best books that I've found in my studies as a
psychologist,
there's about 20 of them.
Go read those books and that'll put you head and shoulders ahead.
There's a lot of them are logs because psychologists pressure the animals.
Experimental psychologists at the neuroscience is a great strides and
understanding the way the brain works.
He really need to know about that cause it's,
it's profound and interesting and relevant to net.
There's a list of books written by the great clinicians.
I think they're unbelievably useful as well.
So we'll read all those books that if you want to understand the psychology
that'll read that.
Yay.
So this one,
that's it.
Dr. Peterson,
what do you do to relax and have a good time?
I come here to answer questions from the audience.
[inaudible]
is he
your
cat litter?
Reforming cycling is
gentleman Jack,
when you were
asking me like mine in how people get back on the world.
Well,
technical last from that,
which is,
you know I learned this from reading 30 years ago.
You wrote this essay called placed between the ego and the unconscious through
work of genius.
And hit warns people who deal with are like,
what are the things you
don't confuse the ideas with cell.
You know,
like I hated watermelon.
A lot of it are some of the biological,
some of them that you have to be very careful not to cheap credit.
No,
I'm,
fortunately I've been able to step up.
These things might be articulated at least what I think could be,
but the ideas and the stories vastly predate me.
They're going to be here a lot longer,
so it's nice to be able to participate in and then to maybe help shed some light
on them I suppose.
But I'm very careful to distinguish that from meat.
So,
and you need to do that.
And you say,
I say board of inflation,
which would be a kind of narcissistic ready to be awesome I suppose.
And it's a very dangerous,
that's a very dangerous risk when you're investigating these sorts of things.
But if you're a property terrified about the negative consequences,
worst excesses,
Michael.
Well,
I
leave.
It's sort of sort of university drew in an ethical sense.
You know he's there.
That's actually can't tell you exactly why
I was trying to day life.
Isn't he adorable?
Burdensome?
No,
because it's beyond those trained killed us.
It's beyond us.
It's like,
well what do you do?
The base of the new Boston problems,
often impossible solution and they lost the solution leads to voluntary bear.
That
group.
One of the strange thing is I think we can do that and so I would say at minimum
psychologically speaking,
Christ isn't exempt flaw that.
Right.
And so something to aim at.
Of course that's it.
That's it.
What see the thing about these ideas too is you can easily dismiss them because
it is the case that our culture has a Judaeo Christian pollination and that
means something.
It means,
it means we all these truths to be self evident and that's what it means.
It's the self evidence in that statement and the self evidence has something to
do with the fact that you know in your country and my country,
the individuals to be of this of intrinsic value not given by the state and
weighed about intrinsic value and worthwhile and I ended up up,
up,
up a fundamental responsibility cause the weight of the state calls on your
shoulders.
Just have terminology.
Our culture is founded on seems to be doing pretty well.
So that's something we can just dispense the thought.
There's something to it.
So,
well,
well for me it's,
I don't feel that I
pushed myself up to the limits of what I know.
And then hopefully I'll be silent after that.
And if I learned some more so that I actually know,
well maybe I can talk about it,
but until that time try it out,
we would actually,
oh,
not the answer.
I think what I've found with these stores decrease,
they go,
there's no wall.
God knows how complicated picks,
really odd.
Tear,
complicated,
satisfied,
satisfaction.
The satisfaction question,
you know.
And I think that's the right answer.
Just satisfaction questions.
It's the right gas,
you know,
something like that.
So he'll want to run out of things to do anyways.
So
very rare
art.
Yeah.
Well you never know.
Whatever possibilities.
It's certainly be gratifying to go around from city to city doing these talks.
And so,
you know,
but that's a lovely thing.
One of the,
somebody asked him about coffee.
No,
no,
but I can tell you what I experience and
wherever I go now
I need
a touching story telling them just want extra or something like that.
We say they tell me something about that state your life.
Was He in a disordered state?
In one form or another?
Have sometimes severely disordered.
God,
I can't tell me the other day it was so cold and the more I talk for 10 seconds,
he said year and a half ago I just got out of jail.
Now I'm married,
I have a child.
I just bought my own apartment because he was watching my lectures,
you know and so well so the reason I broke that up cause you were talking about
law,
what's extraordinary gratified.
Whoa.
This is,
there's plenty of that to me.
So it seems like it's going quite well and see how you can help out with that
continued,
you know my,
my set more sensible park is expected.
Just seem too crazy to be sustainable.
But
yeah,
six year old,
I would say you need to talk to your partner,
your disciplinary scrap,
decide where do you live in is.
And be honest about that.
It's costly from what you've told my suspicions,
allowing yourself,
MMM
[inaudible] wishes.
You've asked me at this.
Stop it.
See what happens.
My suspicions are liking [inaudible] attitude.
You have to have a discussion about that,
but you're
getting it in front of me and good for giving.
You finally sat and he's a Bush character.
What that means in part,
he really well socializing because a kid like that wants to go where the lines
like it isn't just tossed.
The light can be this thick,
vague,
her kid like that.
Oh No,
no.
He wants to know where the lions and the advantage to that.
If you can show exactly where the line is.
Perverse behavior,
keeping him on unbelievably sophisticated social.
So that's the advantage in that kind of emotion is what I would say.
It also sounds like he's tough enough
sphere.
My suspicions are the liking better.
My son was like,
that is a tough path.
Is that right from the right?
And one of the things that I experienced was that,
you know,
to him and humiliate me and my wife is Kevin Thompson candies mushed 11,
10,
okay.
For the next three days.
He gets a movement every time.
It really shocked because I wasn't sure if that would happen,
but you know,
he's looking for
solo or
maybe
he won't buy being reasonable.
You just in the very strategies version will be the real harm even though there
might be a lot of sparks and the like,
that's also part of the testing so that
uh,
or
no,
you feel me like so many and dealt with things around you do all
the mask.
Most people aren't.
In that situation I have had was tangled up Sophie,
he fixed my thinking and we fixed one of them.
You
wait
what?
He's doing
good.
It does know there's Christian Christianity that
might have a big
lot of that
are,
that doesn't mean it's awesome.
So I've seen people
take [inaudible] in your life,
that's for sure.
Yeah,
sure.
Rolling.
Yeah,
it's good.
The restaurant
you might want to just speed through because it was an issue I tried to workout
in them,
which is the relationship between disciplines.
You know,
you can think of Moses,
oh say well if you take one,
half of those other paths are those other paths
and your potential has the mat step your pants story.
Peter Pan Wants to stay a kid because Penn needs every essentially it's so he
wants to retain the infinite possibility of child
but then he ends up king in the lost boys.
Like he never,
lamb will never like this exist.
And who wants to be king was is anyways cause he sees Kevin Hart capital is a
tire.
Right.
And the reason is the tire just cause he's terrified.
Yeah.
[inaudible] it's already got a piece.
So how gets a target is terrified of care,
lead a panel properly with the CS and the dollar this year or is keen in lost
boys and he doesn't get when the either,
so,
okay.
So I'm sure that
it's okay to make a decision.
You know,
you limit yourself.
But in that limiting also spam yourself.
Like if you,
this is what,
in science you can pick out a new problem called the school
and when you start to work on that,
it expands.
You get disciplined in the Spanish,
and so you make some constraints and the constraints of relationship,
they become stranger career and you accept it.
It was a discipline yourself.
And the consequences of that is that that expanse of passing the modeling.
So
potential as a child discipline,
that it's a real system of constraints,
a sacrifice 12 to sacrifice all those other potential
pay off.
As you discipline yourself,
you start to expand out.
So
the way that I deal with that,
usually my clinical practices implemented the best plan you have to,
well,
I'm going to wait around for a better class.
That's not a good plan because you're not informing yourself while you're
waiting around.
So if you implement a plan,
it's not a perfect plan.
At least you'd know why it's a role specific.
Exactly.
What's wrong?
Damn lab.
Sorry.
We'll see.
You lose a lot less by sacrificing that.
You think that the game,
so that's what it looks like to me moving forward.
Man.
That's right.
Well,
life's short room.
Horrible.
That's the call of adventure.
And even having stories like you know,
constantly would those God calling them to and they do it,
you know?
But it's better than standing where you are.
Right?
You rag magnate
and
bitter bitterness.
No,
just just one of the ways that you could tell,
you can tell,
one of the things that council people do,
and I talked about this like is consult you resent,
hey,
let's say that he knows where your resentment like,
okay,
why are you present?
There's only two reasons.
One is you're used to sit and wine and you should grow the hell up and accept
the responsibility hospital possible.
One possibility number two is you're taking too much onto yourself without
sufficient recommends who reward.
So you're taking advantage of yourself,
where you're allowing yourself.
It's one of those too.
It's like,
okay,
so how do you figure out which one it is all suspect the first one,
right?
Because you should always be a little suspicious in relationship to yourself as
a little helpful that way.
And I don't mean accessing to be skeptical,
you know,
trust.
They might say,
no one knows I need all your taken way too much then.
Then you have to figure out how you reward yourself for that shit.
Some of it so that you have,
because you have to be just to yourself.
You know,
I said,
when did you take on as much responsibility as you can?
But that also means as much as pat,
if you're starting to get presented with,
that's often an assignment you've taken on too much,
grinding yourself into the ground.
It's a bad strategy from a sustainability perspective.
So it's all your present and see,
because you want to be able to iterate.
If you want to be able to maintain the burden across time and resentment,
the assignment or that you've taken on such a level,
you can't do that.
That's a partial answer to that.
So what you're saying,
monogamy,
I mean,
if you're gonna,
if you're going to accuse someone of something,
you shouldn't use the book.
Something that someone was somewhere,
I bet if we believe
that the state should intervene and distributed
well [inaudible] recruiters,
no.
Okay.
All sorts of immediately.
Cause I do a lot of media here.
But no,
I've never heard from Chenin four again.
But I didn't reach out to her after that.
After the first week.
Right through it.
It's a media look,
why don't we actually do this gifts.
It could actually have a conversation.
And she said,
well I'll think I'll wait until it dies down to this trouble those down
[inaudible] it was a funny situation.
No,
I
haven't lost the big chop it up.
Five minutes.
Three Boston could like NBC,
NBC,
worst job,
anyone.
That was my calling.
It was so,
it wasn't even so much that it was,
although
it was so amateurish.
Okay.
It's not malicious,
but it would be stupid.
That's a really bad combination because they put up the edit version,
I mean whatever the action of video.
And so then people on Youtube just said,
well
I expected more from,
you know,
and so.
So anyways,
I haven't heard back from,
and I don't really expect.
So I think it's the city for enforcement order
this understanding that that annoys me.
Most days I,
he's been accused of a baby to what you post modernism,
new marks that the Sukkot philosophers
know that postmodernism is skeptical and Ben and narratives admins,
it's not commensurate Marxism.
It's like,
yeah,
I know that in that the blood post modernists is having to seek a particular,
now
it's like they're,
they're using the ignorance on a philosophical topic with the actual situation
is,
is that just might the fact that those doctrines are not commensurate,
they're juxtaposed constantly.
That's how my misunderstanding,
that's the confusion of the people in the aggregate in academia.
So that's the most annoying.
So it's,
and it's not that,
so
[inaudible] is unbelievably unworn cause he knew nothing about them.
So it was just cash shooting off his mouth.
You know,
like,
I
mean I have plenty of experience with so called minority communities.
Like I get to use that terminology or minorities or communities,
but you know,
he doesn't know a damn thing about what I know about,
about people who've already now and then just assess the situation.
So,
you know,
it was,
he was very,
he had a pretty decent rhetorical kissed.
He could be charismatic and a good sense of humor,
but a lot of cheap shots.
Like when I pushed him on white privilege thing,
it's like,
all right,
fine ma'am,
if I net terms all he did was accurate.
That was,
uh,
an assault.
Like,
no,
it's not an assault.
We specify your damn returns,
all that,
it was a main become irritating.
It's like,
yeah,
it made me think.
And now you're irritating.
Yeah.
So,
and there's all sorts of schools of philosophy,
physics as well that our unbelievably,
he can just,
it's very,
very,
very complicated.
And it's not a matter of truth.
Here's the truth is associated with how you act.
There's a truth.
It's associated with what the world's is.
No one knows how
the cake is.
Katherine's identified.
These are very,
very complicated for all known.
If they seem self evident,
the only reason they seem self evident as you the dark one.
And that's what you know,
and it seems self evident.
There's like 30 of them and they fight,
they fight like half,
so
yeah.
Hmm.
Yeah.
Uh,
well,
so,
so you know,
you said when you deconverted that you went through your,
part of the reason for that is that materialist atheism doesn't produce an
ethic.
That's a real problem.
And that's because there aren't things about materialism.
There's lots of things about the truth.
You can tell that by the technology will Howard is grass material,
but the downside of materialism and there's technical reasons for this stuff is
happening.
So it doesn't provide the way guiding yourself in the world.
That's actually a huge needle.
We have guidance.
So this is part of the problem that I have with Sam Harris for example,
is he tries to conjure an ethic code of his materialistic atheistic.
It's like,
well,
good luck with that.
It's not obvious how to do that.
And that doesn't make me a critic of materialism.
I'm a scientist.
I know,
I know the utility of the materialistic view mode and I'm very much appreciative
of the tech I want you to do is produced.
But bridging that gap to an ethic that's a big Bro.
And it's partly the reason that it's a problem is because science,
Chase's epics power up the argument technically.
Because what most schools can do,
if you're a science,
sorry,
get rid of the value judgements.
Well,
that's not because the system,
it's because they interfere with your description of that lies beyond no
judgements,
but there's still the domain of value and contentment science camp 10 women say,
well,
if you say,
it doesn't exist.
It's like,
no,
that's wrong.
It's seriously,
seriously wrong.
It even exists as an empirical phenomena,
limited universe of value are we're,
we're,
we're neurologically adapted to a world of value to the serious flaws in that
serious flaws in them and breezy.
And it's hard on me because if you're hearing materialistic in your outlook and
you don't have an ethos to fall,
a tie was,
and I would say that's actually proof that there's something wrong with the
theory.
The theory makes you whole us and,
and,
and deployed to the purpose and,
and what relates to bear to the suffering of life with no recourse.
If there's something wrong with period,
at least that's,
that's a possibility.
That's what it looks like to me.
This is,
you know,
this is something else,
but you can go on after me.
There wasn't my decision Harris,
but I think that's mostly because they don't understand what the hell I'm
talking about.
One of the things neat you said was the truth serves life.
That's an definition
definition.
Say Well no one truth is truth is what you extract from an aggregation of
material fast find.
That's definition too,
but that doesn't,
it doesn't mean that that definition is a priori.
Correct.
Because you're not just,
you're not just a fact gathering creature.
In fact,
your heart in fact cavity creature at all.
There's something that striving to live,
we need a truth that loves to distract live.
There's no evidence that the materialistic viewpoint provides that.
You say,
well,
it's complete.
It's like there's no evidence that it's complete and not only best separately.
The constant revision was like 15 years ago we found out that we didn't even
know what 95% of the universalist made up.
There's plenty of surprises yet to come.
So,
so drew is the tricky thing then to tricky vague.
It's not self evident by any stretch of the imagination.
You whoa,
why didn't you take them to church?
Yeah,
solve the problem.
And what's your advice for people with young children that maybe
you're stroking the church?
It's like,
I don't know,
I be trying to puzzle it out.
Uh,
I have a friend and this chocolate passion,
he likes,
he likes the liturgical ceremonies,
you know,
and he ever to go to the one in Seattle.
And I have to say we actually for that I've always had,
which was I can hardly wait til this is all,
you know.
[inaudible]
what was,
it doesn't always have,
I really wasn't a fan of school.
I had plenty of years that I was there.
And I think it's sitting in those,
in that
context brings that up.
I was so bored at school like I to just like all my things,
like I was serious before and I've had enough of that.
No,
I mean one of the things when I look back,
religious education,
you know,
cause I went to [inaudible],
I did learn the stories,
you know,
I was familiar enough with the story.
So they were in my imagination,
had turned out to be out.
Unbelievable work.
So I would say if you don't bring your kids to church,
then you have a problem with how the world of it,
where the store.
So because church has done a pretty good job preserving the transmitting stories
and I think the stories are necessary and useful.
So,
but I don't have a better solution than that.
Yeah,
you put
wild.
Well you could,
but it takes a lot of discipline with them.
You know,
it's often something that you might want to parse off to someone else.
I mean,
maybe it can handle it.
Maybe we'll do it.
You can read to them,
so on.
But if it's a major commitment,
so yeah,
I'd like to say yes.
You know,
they learn most of the stories could be in my house.
So maybe I managed that.
Oh,
I'm very ambivalent about that because part of me thinks that I should go.
Probably I should go.
Okay.
Um,
you said that you,
uh,
sit here of individual be a collection of semi-independent motivations.
And I was wondering if that scales up to say a business with maybe like a horde
of consciousness.
They don't wonder Mike that also scale up to say a government maybe could,
the way you conceptualize this rules maybe apply to some of these people
wondering what should the principles of maybe self governance be?
Maybe if we figure out maybe
that scales up
question to that brings up is how does kind of looking inside avoid becoming
jingoistic right?
So like if,
if if the government is looking into itself first in order to solve its
problems,
what separates that and then that same question skills down like how do you a
and being self centered when you're focusing on,
you see what I'm saying?
Yeah.
It becomes obvious when you scale it up,
but how does it would,
when it scales
me self centered is actually a good solution to the problems that you,
you know,
because you might say as a collection of semi autonomous spirits,
which is certainly the psychoanalytic point and I think a biological viewpoint
as well.
I mean you,
you are a center that degration but you're definitely also a collection of semi
autonomous processes.
You know,
um,
the question is how to bring those into the unity.
You might say,
well you do that by,
I don't pick the self centered perspective to bring those into unity,
but unity isn't,
isn't self centered.
And I think the reason for that,
and I kind of like that tonight,
you get those things operating harmoniously together.
Just what you do is socialize a child.
They have to be serving the child's interest now but in a way that doesn't need
to fear what the child's interests as it propagates across time.
And that's an unbelievably tight set of constraints.
And you see that operating,
I didn't talk about this time.
And you see that offer even in the animal kingdom,
you know when animals organized there hierarchies I know that aren't going to
organize themselves in a manner of its purity,
self-serving if they're,
if they're social animals and they also organize them in a way.
Keeps the rights of the other elements in mind as they organized the threats.
Yeah.
The rats are like the walls are like the chimpanzees know so,
so that's self center need.
It doesn't need to work parameters much less for us.
It's so,
and I think it's because things have,
I think it's because things have to iterate across time,
headed up the rules for successful iteration produce very,
very tight constraints on behavior in any particular situation.
So you get an emergent debt.
What do you think that scales the same way.
The bigger you get to say with the company and with,
with maybe a governor like,
well I don't know because I think things can get so fake and he just call,
you know,
I think that's the lesson of the Tower of Babel.
It might even be the lesson up.
Uh,
the European Economic Union might be less than that.
The United States too,
because sometimes I take that about the last,
I think it's just to me,
certainly California
[inaudible]
so big.
It is clear that it can be
like what you do to your presidents.
It's just like
too much.
It's just too much.
Oh,
it's 300 million people.
Luckily it's the person
that's part of it.
We are addressing them to make the units more autonomous.
No,
sorry,
this May
[inaudible] [inaudible]
I can't give you any detail just
because I don't know what he said.
Well,
I'm glad.
So then for you guys to do it and not only you and I just had a core like we
were just kind of thing.
So the ones that,
hey,
this is amazing,
but it's also kind of mediator,
I think other folks to be hopefully more rise to all because of one of the
[inaudible] just really special time.
Reuben,
the one thing
I
find that I'm sure you pick up on this bill,
Sam,
about what clubs and that kind of have that similar kind of mid eighties
about religion
and hopefully someday.
What I noticed is you said a little bit here earlier,
but not with kind of the tone.
What's it?
Some of the times it comes across.
My concern is that he's such an awesome time.
There's an origin,
a polarization of sharecroppers.
If some of the posts he was on paper,
um,
what's today?
And I noticed
like here,
I would see
recoverable the careful way.
Not to fix it too much on you,
but just as you're,
as you said,
these are,
these are cut of,
maybe the presentation is something,
but it is or not,
but just like seeing him kind of doing some variation of the same.
And the reason why is that why it's important because
I think you guys had an opportunity to really,
just because of the nature of folks who work with are perceived to be
conservative,
are going to the attack.
Be careful not to,
you almost have to be stark apartments before any power was every possible
energy.
Yes.
Because sometimes they ask,
you get so cash in your life.
Luckily the people that aren't that is to certainly go,
maybe this is,
what am I going to say
and
be that example.
That's right.
Exactly.
[inaudible] [inaudible].